[Musique]
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de Taïwan
François
nous vous retrouvons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle thinkerview
direct vous connaissez oui j'ai quand
même pas mal vu vos interviews c'est
très intéressant mais c'est quand même
long
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement alors je m'appelle ou tuto
François Roux je suis ambassadeur de
Taïwan en France avant ça j'étais le
numéro 2 with ministre des Affaires
étrangères et avant ça je t'ai
professeur des universités donc je ne
suis pas un diplomate de carrière je
suis plutôt un ambassadeur nommé
politiquement donc j'ai enseigné pendant
17 ans dans une université à Taïwan les
relations internationales la science
politique et avant ça j'avais fait des
études en France pendant presque dix ans
je suis venu en France en 1989 c'était
la fin de la guerre froide nous on était
encore tervenait des records dans dans
un système autoritaire on était pas
encore une démocratie voilà donc je suis
venu en France je remercie toujours la
France qui m'a ouvert les yeux
qui m'a fait découvrir le monde et dans
ma carrière est très simple
étudiant après professeur d'université
après dipomat voilà si vous voulez
comprendre connaître plus posez-moi
encore des questions
on est là pour ça c'était bien en tous
les cas je tenais à
remercier votre staff
qui a bouquiné l'interview sans nous
demander les questions donc vous savez
pas quelle sauce vous allez être manger
donc rien que pour ça mes respects
pour détendre un peu l'atmosphère
qu'est-ce que vous aimez dans votre pays
mis à part le fait que ça va vous a
ouvert les yeux vous connaissez les
spécialités culinaires françaises je
vais vous poser une question tout de
suite indiscrète pendant vos 10 ans
d'études pourquoi vous n'êtes pas marié
avec une Française
[Rires]
ah ça c'est une question
c'est à dire
comme je suis venu en France mais
je ne suis céder j'avais je suis venu
pour faire d'études pour découvrir la
France et j'avais toute ma famille qui
était à Taïwan ma famille c'est quelque
chose qui me tient beaucoup et
donc je connaissais aussi
c'est à dire des c'est à dire que
pour rentrer à Taïwan parce que ce sera
le but de la fin de mes études après je
me suis dit amener une Française à
Taïwan ce serait peut-être pas si simple
et puis tout simplement l'occasion ne
s'était pas présenté et donc on m'avait
dit à l'époque oui pourquoi je ne suis
pas je n'avais pas même pas de copine
française dit mais c'est comme ça c'est
peut-être je n'étais pas assez brillant
à l'époque et donc le destin a fait que
je me suis pas marié après une française
mais ça pourrait être une bonne chose si
la vie peut se refaire vous êtes marié
pardon vous êtes marié oui je suis marié
j'ai j'ai deux enfants
une fille de 20 ans je suis très content
d'avoir une fille de 20 ans et puis un
fils de 18 ans mais je dois dire ce
n'est pas facile du tout parce que je
suis maintenant en France depuis cinq
ans je suis arrivé en 2018 et j'avais
voulu les amener vous voyez 20 ans il y
a derrière l'époque la fille avait 15
ans mon fils avait 13 ans j'avais voulu
les amener pour faire des îles en France
comme moi pour bien parler le français
mais nous sommes une démocratie je suis
arrivé en 2018 je le répète 2019 2018
fin 2018 mon parti a perdu l'élection
régionale de groupe c'est lequel votre
partie de dppp le parti au pouvoir
actuel donc nous avons perdu l'élection
de gros donc je me suis dit bon je vais
peut-être rentrer bientôt c'est comme ça
un ambassadeur nommé politiquement et
2019 il y a eu aussi des gilets jaunes
donc c'était pas pour aux yeux des de ma
famille ce n'est pas très très stable
ici en France 2020 ma président ne gagne
de gros je dis ah très bien je vais
finalement pouvoir les amener en France
et tout de suite la crise de covid 19
donc je suis resté en France pendant
deux ans et demi sans rentrer à Taïwan
et
l'année dernière après deux ans et demi
ma fille et je vais rentrer dans
l'univers mon fils maintenant termine le
lycée ils n'ont plus envie de venir ni
leur oui maintenant c'est à Taïwan leurs
amis sont à Taïwan donc d'une certaine
façon je les ai pas vraiment vu
grandir dans une période importante
c'est l'âge d'adolescence ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose que je regrette
beaucoup et voilà la raison
c'est à dire que c'est je crois c'est
presque le seul regret que je suis
maintenant ici en France vous avez
écouté notre spécialité nos spécialités
culinaires ou pas du tout vous avez fait
quelques restos en France qu'est-ce que
vous avez apprécié le plus qu'est-ce qui
vous a le plus
surpris en France
si vous parlez de la gastronomie alors
si je le dis ne rigolez pas sur moi
voilà pour rigoler d'ailleurs mais je
vous autorise à parler un peu de vin si
vous voulez aussi avec modération
donc quand j'avais fait des études en
France je dois encore une fois remercier
la France à l'époque je mangeais souvent
dans les restos U vous savez j'avais
commencé à je crois 8 francs ou 9 francs
quelque chose comme ça et je veux dire à
l'époque j'étais venu en France
j'étais un étudiant simple donc c'était
la seule façon pour moi de découvrir je
vais pas dire la gastronomie mais la
cuisine française et j'aimais bien et
donc à travers le resto eu qui bien sûr
c'est la base de la cuisine française
mais on pouvait quand même tester pas
mal de choses et donc il y a des choses
qui sont restées dans dans mon cœur par
exemple le poireau vinaigrette c'est que
ça reste encore un plat que j'adore de
temps en temps l'avocat avec des
crevettes c'est aussi mais si vous
parlez une chose que vraiment j'aime
bien et que je ne trouve pas vraiment
Taïwan c'est le pigeon rosé
l'andouillette tout ça vous voyez ce
sont des choses que moi
ce sont créer des plats de luxe de ma
part moi j'aime bien les choses c'est
les places simples les places simples
c'est facile à cuisiner et puis je
faisais
pigeon c'est après je vais dire après le
début c'était le poireau vinaigrette
après le cuisiner ou pas du tout
je n'ai pas vraiment appris à cuisiner
je le fais je regarde les autres comment
ils font donc mais maintenant je pense
pour faire un bon plat ce n'est pas si
difficile si on met notre temps quand
j'étais étudiant à Paris à l'époque
j'avais le temps c'était beaucoup plus
libre premièrement donc j'avais le temps
d'aller au marché de choisir pardon le
radis aussi c'est juste que j'aime bien
leur a dit c'est qu'on ne trouve pas
chez nous le petit le petit le petit
pour mettre avec le sel
du beurre voilà voilà donc tout ça ce
sont des choses à l'époque enfin après
maintenant je pense avec avec Youtube
site internet je pense ce n'est pas si
difficile de faire un bon plat français
mais il vous faut avoir du temps et ce
que il manque beaucoup donc c'est à peu
près comme ça
répondre il faut aussi l'âme française
pour cuisiner ah oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai on est très content de
vous recevoir
on a besoin de vous de votre point de
vue sur ce qui se passe avec la Chine
avec Taiwan ce qui se passe dans la
région
on va poser des questions de
géopolitique de finances peut-être de
guerre on va poser des questions
hard très bien je suis là je suis là
pour ça
déjà on va faire un peu d'histoire
Taïwan c'est quoi l'histoire de Taiwan
alors
je suis très content que vous m'avez
posé cette question parce que j'ai comme
trouvé le monde la France et souvent
tombée dans le narratif chinoises pour
dire que Taïwan appartient à la Chine
depuis l'éternité je peux vous couper
oui
on vous appelle Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
mais la France ne vous reconnaît pas
Taïwan justement et alors je vous laisse
continuer justement la France n'en
connaît pas Taïwan
après je vais revenir un peu sur ces
questions diplomatiques mais tout de
suite
Taïwan vous savez je pense pour les
Français qui sont un peu plus Seigneur
quand ils ont appris
ce territoire le nom c'était Formose
non plus n'est pas si petit que ça si
vous me permettez le territoire Taïwan
c'est comme les Pays-Bas donc c'est
quand même c'est que ça présente comme
quelque chose la population Taïwan c'est
24 millions c'est exactement comme la
population d'Australie donc c'est
quelque chose
alors au début à Taïwan c'était un
endroit
je veux dire que personne ne connaissait
donc il y avait que des Aborigènes après
le premier pouvoir installer à Taïwan ce
que les Européens ont complètement
oublié
alors c'est 1624
le nom de Formose a commencé à être
connu je crois
par les Portugais c'est le Portugais qui
nous ont donné ce nom là en 1624 les
Hollandais sont venus s'installer à
Taïwan alors il faut savoir que quand
quand je dis que Taïwan n'était pas du
tout chinois c'est que c'est très simple
si je m'approche vers toi et je veux
prendre je t'appartient alors supposons
que je suis plus fort que toi
je prends ton téléphone tu vas quand
même te battre pour résister je vais
d'abord poser les questions
d'accord non je continue là-dessus
c'est-à-dire ce que je voulais dire
c'est que quand les Hollandais se sont
venus installer à Taïwan il y a pas eu
de il y a pas une guerre donc des
Chinois l'ont laissé faire c'est-à-dire
pour eux Taïwan aussi c'était un
territoire éloigné et donc les les ondes
sont installés au sud de Taïwan c'était
pas tout Taïwan ensuite les Espagnols au
nord de Taïwan les Chinois n'ont rien
dit non plus vous pouvez peut-être pas
dire grand-chose
oui non non c'est parce que il ne savait
pas ce qui se passait à Taïwan il y
avait il y avait pas de chinois selon
une étude en 1624 quand les Hollandais
sont venus s'installer Internet vous
savez à Taïwan il y avait à peu près
d'une université à l'Université
Nationale Taïwan à l'époque il devrait
avoir 100000 aborigènes 100 000 et puis
1000 européens 700 chinois et 200
japonais voyez les Européens des mêmes
plus nombreux que
les Européens étaient même plusieurs
nombreux que les Chinois donc il y a pas
de guerre après les Européens il y a eu
c'est-à-dire en général
de l'empire des mines on était entre les
mines et les signes et d'ailleurs ce
général c'était un métier sa mère des
japonaise donc son père était chinois
c'était un pirate
il est venu de Chine pour conquérir
Taïwan on appelait kosinga donc ça c'est
quand je dis conquérir il avait utilisé
la force donc c'était 1600 contre qui
contre les Hollandais qu'il y a Taïwan
qui est occupait la première guerre
entre la Chine et Taïwan et bah Taïwan
des défendu par des Européens alors
comme l'histoire le dit les Européens
l'ont perdu donc ce général Migne est
venu s'installer aussi de Taïwan pour
créer un royaume qui s'appelait le
royaume pour la paix de l'Est
après ce général mine c'est le tour de
la Chine est tombée dans les mains des
signes alors il faut savoir les signes
c'est pas vraiment les purs chinois ce
sont les Mandchous dont les Mandchous
après ont vu qu'il y avait un territoire
qui était un peu loin d'une grande
empire alors à leur tour ils sont venus
attaquer Taïwan alors cette fois-ci
encore c'est la force parce que Taïwan
n'appartenait pas audit les signes les
manchous ont gagné c'est des 1662 donc
Taïwan est tombé dans l'empire des
signes et donc c'est avec ça que la
Chine actuelle revendique de Taïwan
[Musique]
le dernier empire de la Chine c'est ça
donc le mot Chine vient le mot Ching ça
devient là encore un empire encore plus
ancien
le premier empereur de Chine donc
on est entré vraiment dans la région
chinois alors il faut savoir quelque
chose quand même c'est à dire l'empire
des signes c'est une grande empire bien
sûr à l'époque c'était moderne mais ils
ont ils avaient du mal à contrôler tout
Taïwan pourquoi parce que Taïwan c'est
aussi un territoire rempli de montagne
268 montagnes au-dessus de 3000 mètres
268 la montagne la plus haute de Taïwan
est plus haute que le Fujiyama du Japon
c'est alors de 4000 mètres donc vous
savez pour contrôler tous ces endroits
montagneux il va falloir une structure
politique moderne il faut avoir des
outils modernes et la Chine détiennent
disposées pas donc il contrôlait une
société tribale
et il contrôlait que les côtes les côtes
alors
1895 on entre on est on est dans la
conflit entre la Chine et le Japon alors
Taïwan n'est pas dedans parce que Taïwan
fait partie de l'empire du signe le
Japon
[Musique]
il se retire de Taïwan
oui les Japonais se retient le terrain
oui donc là on est en 45 donc il se
retire de Taïwan au bénéfice de qui
au bénéfice des Nations Unies donc c'est
à dire qu'il y avait c'était au bénéfice
de la Chine où c'était au bénéfice de
ils ont tellement peur ils rentrent chez
eux
c'est-à-dire au bénéfice de des alliés
qui sont venus s'installer à Péronne
parce que l'armée de chianga Shake
n'avait pas une marine donc les
Américains qui les ont transporté à
Taïwan alors il faut il faut je dois
vraiment insister là-dessus parce que
souvent quand on parle de ça en France
ça se répète à chaque fois que tu en
cachec serait-il s'installe à Taïwan
dans une provan chinoise
n'oubliez pas ce que j'avais dit en 1195
1895 Taïwan et CD au Japon
officiellement reconnu par le droit
international par le traité Shimano
c'est qui donc en chunk échec se refuge
il s'installe à l'intérieur en 1945
Taïwan était encore une un territoire
japonais et même en 49 quand il avait
perdu la guerre civile et s'installe à
Taïwan c'était encore territoire
japonais le Japon a abandonné la
souveraineté one en 1952 avec le traité
de San Francisco parce que si on se
trompe sur ce que je viens de dire tout
ceci me trouve un chinoise donc ta
immédiatement entre dans le narratif
chinois et c'est ça aussi le gros
problème à chaque fois que le monde
avait compris comme histoire de Taïwan
et la Chine en effet non tu avais été
encore un territoire japonais il est
devenu enfin il est pas devenu mais
celui-là il a été abandonné par le Japon
en 1952 et souvent ce qu'on dit à Taïwan
c'est-à-dire le problème de soigner n'a
jamais été résolu parce que le Japon
abandonne Taïwan mais ne dis pas qu'il
donne à qui
voyez et donc s'engager s'installe dans
un territoire japonais
abandonné par le goût en japonais et
nous sommes héritage trois périodes ce
que je viens trois périodes et de 4
éléments d'abord les aborigènes après la
période européenne la paire de chinoise
la période de japonaise on est devenu ce
qu'on est aujourd'hui ce qui est
important moi je pense que la
souveraineté Taïwan est devenue une
vraie chose à partir de 1996 qu'on avait
eu notre premier élection présidentielle
au suffrage universel
débarque à Taïwan sur un i décrète que
c'est la République de chez 49 45 ils
envoient simplement en général un
gouverneur pour gouverner Taïwan et
entre temps là il y a eu un quelque
chose très important qui est qui a
marqué l'histoire Taïwan c'est-à-dire le
28 février en 1947 voyez tiens en étant
allié une massacre tous les élites
taïwanais qui ont fait des études à
l'étranger et pourquoi parce que Taïwan
vous savez en étant un état un
territoire japonais moderne on voit
débarquer des soldats de Chine qui sont
pas si modernes que ça et donc il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de conflits c'est
comme un pays sous-développé qui vient
prendre contrôle d'un pays développé et
là il y a eu beaucoup de conflits de
tension et qui a émergé à une sorte de
révolution et qui a fait que l'armée de
changer un massacré beaucoup d'élite
taïwanais
ensuite avec la terre blanche à peu près
20 000 entre 15 et 30 millions on dit
c'est ça
vraiment à les mesurer mais c'est à dire
la plupart des séries tahonnêtes qui ont
fait des études à l'étranger ont été
tués par échec 140 000 prisonniers
politiques
les chiffres n'est pas vraiment en tête
donc
ce que qui est le plus clair c'est comme
vous pouvez le dire c'est à peu près
entre 15000 et 30000 mais je prends la
moyenne 20.000 de
taïwanais qui ont des massacrés par
Jean Gachet donc c'est pour ça aussi à
Taïwan on a un travail qui est en train
de faire des trouver
la transition de de la justice on veut
on essaye de redonner génération entre
les deux cachant qui meurt qu'est-ce qui
prend le pouvoir son fils son fils et
c'est lui qui organise la transition
c'est ça non c'est pas lui la transition
c'est encore après je vous fais une
passerelle allez-y continue alors tu as
réussi après bon il y a eu un président
très très court il y a une certaine
après
c'est le fils de Jean gâché
en 1988 et donc
un président
prendre pouvoir pour la première fois
qui avait été éduqué au Japon
après qui avait travaillé avec le GAMT
devient le président on appelle little
et qui est devenu le père de la
démocratie Taïwan vos parents ils
étaient venus avec les Américains non
mais parent c'est dans ma famille est
venue je crois avec hocinga il y a 300
ans donc nous sommes une famille qui est
installé à Taïwan depuis depuis 300 ans
alors il faut aussi dire quelque chose
que qui était sur place quand ils ont vu
shank échec débarquer
ils ont eu quelle réaction les Taïwanais
plutôt
on fait quand même différence
l'étawanais ce que je voulais dire quand
ils ont vu l'armée
c'est ça aussi nous avons beaucoup de
comptes Taïwan est une vraie démocratie
on a beaucoup de conflits là-dedans les
l'armée chinoise se sont supérieurs
parce que ils ont la guerre les
terminais disent mais ce que vous
représentez n'est pas vraiment un État
moderne donc au début il les avait
applaudis en disant parce que l'Éternel
aussi n'était pas traitée comme citoyen
de première niveau par les japonais ils
aborigènes les abrogènes
n'étaient c'était encore une ce qu'on
appelle une sous-catégorie de sous
l'empire japonais donc au début on avait
eux ils avaient applaudi l'arrivée de
tchergachev mais ça c'est ça c'est
terminé par un massacre donc après
c'est tout ça qui a qui a généré
beaucoup de problèmes entre la
population taïwanaise et la population
chinoise qui est devenue mais maintenant
on est dans une génération qui qui les
Américains qui vous ont débarqué du
moins qu'on débarqué chaque essai
troupes sur l'île est-ce qu'ils se sont
sentis responsables
du massacre en question
c'est une bonne question si
alors quand je vous entends
moi j'ai appris très récemment que
c'était les Américains qui avaient fait
la cour pêcher la Shanks à échec plus de
millions de soldats jusqu'à Taïwan et je
me suis dit Taïwan en fait c'est Made in
USA
alors d'une certaine façon
on a c'est-à-dire l'influence américaine
à Taïwan et est très très forte
dans la façon de marcher à l'armée et
vous avez remarqué oui c'est à dire on a
eu
Taïwan d'une certaine façon et un cas
qui a eu beaucoup de
succès c'est là qui est un modèle de
l'aide américain
les Américains ont aidé beaucoup de pays
dans le dans le monde après la deuxième
guerre mondiale je crois les deux les
trois cas qui ont les plus réussis c'est
la Corée Japon et Taïwan la
philanthropie là pardon c'était de la
philanthropie c'est à dire c'était de
l'aide totalement désintéressée
[Rires]
on reviendra sur l'aide des intéressés
non je crois c'est le monde était
vraiment dans dans la guerre froide donc
d'une certaine façon nous nous servons
aussi une sorte de
d'alliance pour les Américains mais de
l'autre côté il faut pas oublier aussi
que les Arméniens nous ont apporté aussi
mais pas que des Américains c'est
vraiment on appelle le monde libre nous
a apporté beaucoup de pensées
démocratiques que nous considérons
maintenant sont des valeurs que nous
chérissons que nous partageons avec vous
là il y a eu encore des massacres fin
dire des meurtres
à Taïwan pendant l'époque de giangacash
ont beaucoup fait pour sauver
les prisonniers politiques de l'époque
et
les Allemands 1940 000 avec des camps
dignes de ce qu'on a connu de pire nous
en Europe oui oui donc moi je considère
plutôt
que c'est politique le monde c'est pas
fait de noir et blanc donc il y a eu
certainement des problèmes nous avons
certainement été d'une façon
à l'époque une des Américains parce que
la Chine nous étions aussi membre du
Conseil
permanente de c'est que des Nations
Unies la Chine c'est des nous là
je me fais l'avocat du diable les amis
la France jusqu'en 1964 donc il y a eu
vraiment ce dispute de la vraie Chine
alors je dois comme dire quelque chose
parce que après on va dire mais alors
vous êtes chinois oui ou non ça c'était
vraiment des décisions des des des des
des des chefs de d'État le peuple Taïwan
n'a jamais eu la possibilité
occidentaux et Taïwan et Taïwan
n'a jamais eu l'occasion de se prononcer
sur ce sujet là
et donc je pense bien sûr il y a eu tous
ces histoires du réel politique de la
guerre froide mais de l'autre côté
nous remercions
les Américains qui nous ont apporté de
l'aide qui va aussi aider pour le
développement économique également le
Japon tout ça qui a et nous à l'époque
nous saurions progressivement
step by step c'est-à-dire vers vraiment
une une puissance économique et après ça
on a aussi permis de d'évoluer vers une
société démocratique et d'avoir plus de
justice dans dans la société et tout ça
je crois cher pays à dépassé noir ou
dépassé
emprunt de peine
nous nous sommes comme vous maintenant
nous nous faisons des autorréfections
quand on a fait plein d'erreurs nous
nous excuserons quand je vais la
démocratie au Taïwan c'est pas la
démocratie chez nous c'est pas le
paradis chez nous c'est aussi on a aussi
beaucoup de problèmes mais une société
encore une fois je le répète n'est
jamais parfaite et justement il faut
permettre aux gens de ce corriger
c'est-à-dire de réfléchir et de voir
quelle est la vraie justice
quel est le futur de l'humanité en étant
un vrai humain
vous parlez de conduite introspective
c'est-à-dire vous pencher sur les peines
du passé pour avancer d'une façon plus
sereine
comment ça se fait qu'il y a un mémorial
de changa échec digne de
l'époque comment ça se fait que
difficile à répondre
vous aviez un parc avec beaucoup de
statuts de shank échec mais il y a
toujours tout à fait c'est une question
que le gouvernement actuel ça fait débat
à l'intérieur de Taïwan tout à fait
comment ça se fait que dans une
démocratie comme Taïwan on a encore le
statut un statut si géant de Tiana check
au centre de Taipe et donc il y a
beaucoup décisions qui veulent l'enlever
mais vous devrez savoir
la démocratie à Taïwan d'une
dissertation et aussi on
est très seul on n'est pas on est
reconnu que par 13 États le monde se dit
on a encore enlevé un état depuis que
vous avez étudié il y a quelques il y a
moi je crois il y a quelques semaines
qu'est-ce qui vous a retiré la Chine
c'est c'est le Honduras qui est parti
donc on est le monde se dit
souvent neutre mais vous savez la vraie
neutralité c'est vous gardez la même
distance des deux côtés vous parlez avec
les deux côtés et vous ne décidez pas le
sort c'est à dire le futur mais vous
parlez normalement à la Chine
vous ne parlez pas avec Taïwan Taïwan a
droit aucune aucune discussion formelle
vous savez on dit sur un modèle et notre
présidente dès qu'elle est élu elle n'a
plus droit de venir en Europe ou à
l'étranger il met en confinée à
quelqu'un élu aussi fera universel donc
je reviens à dire pourquoi j'ai dit ça
c'est à dire
vous pouvez aussi me causer la question
pourquoi nous gardons cette républocine
qui est si peu reconnue parce que vous
changez pas votre constitution oui voilà
revenons à chanter
le culture de votre de votre ancien
leader il y a très longtemps pourquoi
vous prenez pas assez pour montrer
l'histoire c'est pourquoi
parce que déjà à l'intérieur Taïwan on
n'a pas de consensus là-dessus c'est la
démocratie on doit aussi respecter les
gens maintenant qui sont venus
s'installer à Taïwan et et et c'est pas
immédiatement nous imposer nous imposons
quelque chose que nous considérons qui
est juste mais eux ils ont aussi leur
histoire ils ont aussi leur mémoire
tient qu'à chaque représentant quelque
chose qui a comme résisté en Chine à la
Nasio japonaise donc on doit aussi
respecter leur mémoire et et il y a
notre chose qui est qui est très
difficile aussi pour nous c'est à dire
dès qu'on touche au symbole de la Chine
il y a l'autre Chine qui va pas content
c'est de la chaîne communiste vous savez
la Chine la façon qui ne revendique et
ben c'est à dire nous nous refusons
catégoriquement tout ce qui est de la
République c'est nous hein c'est la
République populaire de Chine le drapeau
tout ça tout ça ça n'existait plus mais
vous n'avez pas le droit de changer si
vous changez et bien c'est considéré
comme une convocation et on vous attaque
donc
à Taïwan il y a plein de choses
nous avons du mal nous voulons être
aussi comme les autres et c'est toucher
à tout ça mais il y a un gros problème
je vous donne un exemple très simple
selon la constitution de la règle de
Chine Taïwan et une province David de
Chine bon la glycine maintenant reste il
reste que Taïwan alors dans les 90 il y
avait encore un gouverneur de Taïwan
constitution de quelle année alors de
1900 à 1934 la concision a été créée en
Chine donc c'est une constitution qui
est fait pour la Chine et à l'époque
quand la caution a été créée Taïwan
n'était pas chinois
et donc je reviens à
à ce que je suis en train d'expliquer
c'est-à-dire en même temps nous avons un
président de de la ville de Chine et un
gouverneur aussi très puissant à
l'intérieur de cette biologie qui est
Taïwan et donc après on a voulu faire
une réforme c'est-à-dire le supprimer
vraiment ce gouverneur élu c'est à peu
près le même phénomène que la Russie de
yens sin à l'époque et cobatchov y
a-t-il
donc ça fait ça fait quand même grand
conflit donc on a on a on a supprimé le
statut de supprimer s'il y en a on a
gelé on a même pas le droit de supprimer
on a gelé la statut de Taïwan pour qu'il
reste un président et même avec ça à
l'époque le monde nous a nous a il est
tout à dire et qu'est-ce que vous êtes
en train de faire là vous êtes en train
de provoquer la Chine ouais il y a des
choses qui se passent par des façons
démocratiques mais on ne peut rien faire
je vous dis encore un exemple là c'est
c'est chose qui m'a vraiment vraiment
marqué et que l'époque j'étais un peu
triste
je crois c'est en 2004 en 2004 on a eu
2004 c'est l'année où on a on a une
autre une autre élection présidentielle
donc le prix dans l'époque avait dit bon
on va essayer de faire un référendum
parce que à l'époque n'avait pas encore
de référendum donc on va faire
référendum demander au peuple taïwenn
Dakar que nous entamons une négociation
avec la Chine une négociation de paix
est-ce que la peur de Taïwan elle est
d'accord s'ils nous continuons à acheter
de l'armement aux États-Unis pour
continuer à se défendre tout à fait
normal vous savez le monde nous a
condamné le monde entier prix dans le
gère Chirac les Allemands les Américains
les Canadiens ils ont tous condamné en
disant vous n'avez pas le droit de faire
un référendum vous êtes en train de
provoquer la Chine
le seul pays qui n'a pas condamné c'est
le Japon le Japon a dit nous avons
abandonné la Suède Taïwan on nous dit
plus rien sur ça donc même vous voyez le
processus de la démocratisation
non ils n'ont rien dit c'est c'est pas
c'est pas votre ça
des Nations Unies il y a pas de question
de s'abstenir il y a seulement une
attitude et donc
pour vous dire que le processus de
démocratisation Taïwan
c'est quelque chose qui a été née à
Taïwan c'est différent de la
démocratisation de la démocratie en
Corée que les Américains protégés du
Japon qui sont aussi protégés nous on
l'a fait nous-même on parlait tout à
l'heure qui a eu beaucoup d'influences
américaines mais d'une façon très
différente donc donc moi je suis très
fier de la démocratie qui était née à
Taïwan et qu'on les a défendues et que
moi j'espère que beaucoup je crois la
plupart interné espère que nous pouvons
continuer à vivre dans cette démocratie
cette cette nation talonaise
je vous laisse reprendre votre souffle
je me permets de boire permettez-vous je
vous en prie
voilà
à l'heure actuelle votre pays le PIB de
Taïwan c'est combien
alors le PIB de Taïwan c'est 800
milliards de dollars américains c'est
exactement comme la Suisse ou comme la
Turquie il y a cinq ans quand j'étais
venu
non non
je vous assure je vais regarder
800 milliards alors on est là 20e
puissance économique du monde il y a 5
ans quand j'étais venu en France on est
où 6 ans je crois on était je crois non
ça doit être 2016 qu'on quand j'étais
nommé Miss adapté l'étranger on était à
600 milliards de dollars on était comme
la Suède dans l'époque quand je
présentais la puissance économie de
Taïwan le disait Taïwan c'est facile
c'est la Suède maintenant c'est c'est la
Suisse ou c'est la Turquie voilà donc
c'est la 20e puissance mais on n'a pas
le droit d'être dans le jeu
combien ça coûte une location d'un 20
mètres ou d'un 40 mètres carrés à taiper
alors le prix
va mettre un 40 m ça doit coûter je
crois
un peu près à
300.000 euros
alors en location en location en
location
en location ça doit coûter
alors que j'ai pas beaucoup d'idées là
dedans mais
au moins
500 euros je pense au moins 500 euros le
salaire médian c'est combien
ça doit être à peu près votre SMIC je
pense 15000 non 1500 1500 euros à peu
près ou 1000 +
je crois on est à peu près à votre 156
de Taïwan vient de dépasser le Japon et
la Corée du Sud cette année donc la vie
à Taipei ça doit être un peu et qui va
dans
alors il faut dire que notre PMB si on
le calcule par le pouvoir d'achat on a
une nettement plus haute que la France
donc
je trouve avec le même salaire nous
vivons mieux à taper nous avons mis à
taper donc des chiffres ça doit être à
peu près pareil que la France mais nous
vivons mieux parce que le prix est moins
cher
de l'inflation chez vous en ce moment à
combien actuellement à combien
on peut vous envoyer Bruno Le Maire pour
vous aider si vous voulez je crois on
m'avait expliqué ça à peu près 10% aussi
c'est aussi c'est aussi pas une chose
agréable c'est pour ça que le parti au
pouvoir le DBP et aussi en difficulté
pour l'élection présidentielle de
l'année prochaine salut de la dette à
Taïwan
je crois la dette à l'étranger c'est
presque 0 parce que comme nous sommes
pas membres de FMI
ni de quoi que ce soit comme
occasion internationale financière nous
avons appris de compter sur nous-mêmes
je crois dans les années 90 qu'on est a
eu la crise financière asiatique que la
Corée du Sud était vraiment en panne
nous nous avons pu rester vraiment en
scène parce que on n'avait pas de dette
et on avait une grande réserve de qu'on
appelait ça de réserve de se dire de
dollars à l'époque
comment Taïwan produit son eau douce et
son électricité
alors avant on avait nos centrales
nucléaires alors
on a
on a eu beaucoup de problèmes pour les
déchets nucléaires parce qu'il faut
savoir Taïwan c'est une île il faut
trouver d'endroit pour mettre nos
déchets et
encore une fois tout ce qui concerne
nucléaire ce sont des questions
sensibles
sur tous les questions qui concernent la
nucléaire ou l'armement on est on subit
une sorte de blocus de la communauté
internationale
si on veut discuter ça tout le monde dit
mais il y a la Chine qui est à côté donc
on peut pas trop discuter avec vous donc
on nous avons abandonné nous avons
décidé d'aborder
l'énergie unitaire
je crois en 2025 nous espérons qu'il y
aura plus de nucléaires
nous espérons de ne plus avoir d'énergie
nucléaire
aussi pour des raisons parce que je peux
vous parler comme vous me coupez souvent
des fois il y a ma pensée qui
des fois qui enfin qui qui flotte donc
je vais parler des génies nucléaires
donc on a nous n'arions pas à résoudre
des scheniculaires en plus on nous avons
aussi des tsunamis nous avons des
tremblements de terre et tout ça ça peut
causer un grand incident nucléaire donc
ce qui fait que nous avons décidé
d'abandonner et donc actuellement nous
dépendons beaucoup du Pétro du gaz nous
travaillons beaucoup maintenant pour
pour l'éolienne nous espérons travailler
la France avec l'Europe pour pour
l'éolienne et aussi l'énergie solaire
quelle consommation électrique par honte
Taïwan ça représente combien de
mégawattheure
il faut me pardonner j'ai pas tous les
chiffres en tête en plus je vous ai vous
m'avez pas donné de questions encore
qu'est-ce que vous connaissez au pic
énergétique
c'est à dire ah oui pic énergétique
le top de capacité de production
d'extraction la déplétion du pétrole
qu'est-ce que vous y creusez un petit
peu à Taïwan ou pas du tout parce que
les économies insulaires sont très
vulnérables à ça c'est vrai c'est vrai
est-ce que vous y réfléchissez un peu
plus que les autres parce que vous êtes
en première ligne alors
nous discutons bien sûr beaucoup de
cette sécurité énergétique et
alors c'est pour ça que nous craignons
vraiment un blocus venant la Chine alors
notre bouclier et bien c'est à dire nous
tenons quand même le cœur du monde parce
que nous avons des semi-conducteurs
Taïwan produit
plus je crois à peu près 60% en général
et c'est une conduite du monde mais
à peu près comme ça
90%. merci pour le là c'est vraiment on
tient le cœur du monde et donc notre
expression en français mais on va pas
l'employer
et donc si la Chine alors si Taïwan
si travaille tout le monde travaille
normalement avec Taïwan on devrait pas
avoir ce problème là parce que d'énergie
parce que là le pétrole arrive le gars
arrive
alors le pétrole arrive surtout du
Moyen-Orient le gaz tout ça d'Australie
pareil de l'extérieur normalement nous
travaillons avec le monde entier donc
ce que nous savons très bien si jamais
il y a une rupture de tous ces énergies
et ben
TSMC c'est-à-dire l'usine qui fabrique
les 5000 conduire depuis tombé en panne
et tout le monde ne pourra pas supporter
on va revenir sur ce sujet juste après
quand on voit les États-Unis sécurisé le
collier de perles vous connaissez le
collier
d'îles qui vont jusqu'à chez vous et
donc depuis des années il y a énormément
de base ça a l'air de stresser les
Chinois
donc ça a l'air de stresser les Chinois
les Chinois en répercussion sont partis
invoquer le traité de la mère de Chine
avec le les traits en 7 traits c'est
quoi l'expression exacte
de toute façon c'est une sorte de ligne
qui qui fait que la mère de la Chine du
Sud les appartient en entier
la Chine avait
considère cette région qui les
appartiennent vers le nom le bois c'est
la mère d'Achille du Sud ça peut aller
jusqu'au port du Vietnam de la Malaisie
et donc
la Chine je pense veut être la première
puissance du monde donc ils en ont
besoin de dominer cette région la Chine
est aussi d'une façon un peu enfermée
par le Japon après Taïwan et après les
Philippines dont il ne peut pas accès
à l'océan Pacifique donc pour eux
premièrement c'est de pouvoir contrôler
ses îles il y a beaucoup d'Américains
Philippines
ça a l'air de les stresser un peu non
alors ça en Corée en Corée c'est pour la
Corée du Nord pose la question est-ce
que vous connaissez la région et les
mentalités sur place beaucoup mieux que
moi oui
il y a beaucoup de bien sûr il y a
beaucoup de militaires américains sur
place
alors il faut savoir aussi la raison
pour laquelle c'est pas les Allemands
qui les ont imposés la Corée a besoin de
ces misères américains les Japonais
aussi
les Philippines aussi ont besoin et
c'est pourquoi tout le monde dit qu'on a
besoin c'est parce que dans ce temps
modernes si on veut leur demander de
quitter déjà ils en sont capables et
puis les philippins ont fait un petit
peu aussi avec
un petit peu aussi ils ont voulu le
faire mais après c'est c'est aussi un
débat donc tous ces pays-là pourquoi
maintenant c'est pas c'est pas ça même
pas qu'ils ont besoin mais demande
encore plus de présence militaire
américaine sur place c'est parce que moi
je considère c'est c'est la Chine qui
les fait peur
on aurait dû être entré dans un siècle
qu'on aura beaucoup besoin moins besoin
de tous ces équipements militaires
c'était un siècle que on est dans
professeur à l'époque la fin de
l'histoire qu'on avait crue
comment s'appelle-t-il la fin de
l'histoire à l'époque vous
faut
pardonnez-moi j'ai aucun souci et donc
on aurait dû je pense si la Chine ne
s'était pas montré si agressif si la
Chine avait aussi
évoluer vers ce que nous avons pensé
c'est à la loi de marché aller permettre
plus de liberté à la Chine je pense
peut-être les Américains seraient le
nombre de ces aurait été diminué au
Japon aux Philippines alors la Corée
moins parce qu'il y a Corée du Nord
c'est une question différente mais comme
la Chine a fait monter c'est montrer
très agressive donc ça c'est la
révolution histoire c'est de montrer qui
s'est évolué vers une autre direction
vous avez des exemples de ça c'est à
dire l'agressivité
la mère de la Chine du Sud la
militarisation monsieur City avait
promis à Monsieur Obama président à
l'époque qui n'allait pas militariser la
mère la Chine du Sud mais ils l'ont fait
la rigidité avec Taïwan c'est
surtout montrer avec Taïwan vous savez
l'année dernière il y a eu 2000 avions
militaire chinois qui ont fait une
incursion dans la zone d'identification
de la défense aérienne taïwanaise
c'est-à-dire tous les jours il y a eu 6
7 avions qui sont chinois qui sont venus
nous dire bonjour
ils sont venus dire bonjour à la radio
ils ont juste testé votre capacité de
radar ils sont les deux les deux disent
bonjour
je dis je dis à cette fois un peu
rigoler mais c'est une pression énorme
de la part de la Chine et nous avons été
obligés à chaque fois aussi de faire
monter nous avions les mirages 2000
d'ailleurs on nous remercions la France
avec Samira lemick continuent à bien
fonctionné de monter à aller les
problèmes de moteur mais vous savez je
voulais vous dire le monde sur cela ne
nous traite pas d'une façon neutre même
c'est-à-dire une façon correcte parce
que il y a que les maintenant ils ont
peur de la Chine tout le monde a peur de
la Chine
c'est pas une question de noir et blanc
je le reconnais
c'est pas simplement si nous si la
France maintenant nous vend
immédiatement des rafales chinois être
tellement en colère que je crois ça crée
une autre instabilité bien sûr nous le
souhaitons donc il y a beaucoup de
choses que moi je souhaite que nous
traversons mais pas forcément sur sur
l'armement donc alors je reviens sur
cette dernière idée je veux dire de qui
qui arrivent de tous les jours et
maintenant l'année dernière aussi avec
la vie de Nancy pellossi vous savez
Nancy pelloti c'est c'est
les auditeurs qui ne la connaissent pas
c'est la Présidente
c'est la présidente de la de l'Assemblée
nationale américaine numéro 3 quoi oui
numéro 3 oui c'est le numéro 3 de numéro
3 c'est selon la position ce qui est
important c'est de l'antipel aussi c'est
comme le président de l'Assemblée
nationale américaine elle a été élue
qui est aussi un pays démocratique
un avion
ouais à force 3 des États-Unis et donc
la rencontre en deux élus la Chine
monsieur City qui n'a jamais été élu se
permet de faire des mala militaires pour
nous menacer cette année c'est pareil
il avait besoin de se dégourdir les
champs avec son armée ça lui a donné un
prétexte
pour aller aux États-Unis vous comprenez
pourquoi je pose la question c'était un
voyage officiel où c'était
potentiellement officiel
potentiellement officiel parce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure je dis le
grand paradoxe de Taïwan tout le monde
dit Taïwan
une démocraties les plus avancées du
monde ne vous aimons les gens sont les
gens sont aimables vous avez vous tenez
aussi le savoir-faire des
semi-conducteurs nous avons besoin de
vous mais je suis désolé on peut pas
parler à vous et vous n'êtes pas
autorisé de faire une visite chez nous
donc vous devez savoir c'est à dire je
vous dis tout à l'heure la présidente
Taïwan dès qu'elle est enfin le ou là
président
d'aller dans le monde entier même pas
même pas un appel de téléphone parce que
Trump m'avait appelé
ma présidence et ça a encore incité la
colère d'Achille mais un appel
téléphonique c'est ça je regrette
beaucoup donc tous ces investiaires ça
alerté naturellement les Japonais les
Coréens parce que là l'année dernière
quand ils ont sur les manominaires des
Chinois ont lancé des missiles autour de
Taïwan et c'est tombé dans les eaux des
droits du Japon donc bien sûr les
japonais ils sont en colère récemment la
Corée aussi le président coréen aussi
essayer de avec simplement dire pour
excuser ou pas non non pas du tout pas
du tout
j'ai rarement vu la Chine s'excuser la
Chine toute demande tout le temps les
autres de s'excuser mais eux ils se leur
doit pour la Chine à tout le monde les
agresse donc ça c'est que ceux qui est
quand même très grave alors les Coréens
aussi sont en train de de changer leur
attitude le président coréen avait
simplement dit que
si jamais ça arrive quelque chose à
Taïwan ça concerne tout le monde c'est
naturel Taïwan ne peut pas par
définition par nature être une affaire
chinoise déjà avec le commerce vous
savez il y a la moitié des containers du
monde qui passe par le détroit de formos
donc s'il y a un conflit qui se passe à
Taïwan tout le monde toucher tout le
monde est touché donc ça ne peut pas
être une affaire interne chinoise donc
le prix d'un coréen ça veut demander
simplement dit s'il arrive quelque chose
à Taïwan c'est comme il arrive quelque
chose dans le monde entier donc ce qu'il
voulait dire c'est qu'il fallait oui
c'est une guerre mondiale donc ça ça n'a
pas pris ça va pas plus au chinois qui
ont tout de suite attaquer le président
coréen donc voyez c'est tout cette
question bah on dit que il faut que la
Corée reste correcte et de ne pas se
mêler dans les affaires intérieures de
la Chine
donc vous voyez c'est Taïwan pour
revenir encore la question qu'on m'a
posé l'agressivité chinoise se montre
presque partout dans la région il faut
pas oublier l'Inde je me souviens il y a
deux ans il y a eu un conflit
frontalière avec l'Inde qui a causé je
crois plus de 100 morts le confirmin ça
se produit régulièrement vous laissez
des troupes en pleine montagne au bout
d'un certain temps ça finit par déborder
un peu non c'est ça
le conflit arrive après ils ont aussi
leurs problèmes de sécurité
et donc la Chine a des problèmes aussi
avec Ouigours avec le Tibet
regardez la violence il y a pas de
problème
bon
selon la chier pour moi il y a plein de
machines ouais selon la Chine le
narratif chinois regardez la violence
qu'ils ont commis à me poser une
question je termine là pour détruire la
démocratie Hong Kong parce que c'est
pour vous dire pourquoi il y a
l'agressivité la violence moi quand j'ai
vu ce qui s'est passé en 2019 la façon
qu'ils ont détruire la démocratie ça m'a
vraiment pas marcher un pays de de
système ça va pas marcher ça fonctionne
plus il y a plus un pays de système
maintenant c'est complètement chinois
les tous les débutés
ils avaient signé un traité
international pour permettre au moins 50
ans le fonctionnement le bon
fonctionnement d'un pays de système il
n'y a pas 25 ans ça a disparu les les
députés qui ont des élus à l'époque à
Hong Kong maintenant sont tous en prison
donc sûr de ça ah oui oui les gens ils
sont tous en prison tout ça il y a plus
ils ont plus libres de faire leur métier
et donc l'agressivité chinoise se
manifeste pourquoi ils sont en prison
les accuses d'être des séparatistes
comme d'habitude tout le monde tout le
monde est séparatiste
si on veut pas être chinois si on a une
vision une pensée différente de la Chine
communiste donc dès qu'on dit on est
différent de ce que les tâches Chinois
disent les séparatistes c'est pour ça
que vous êtes si sensible à simple parce
que dans votre histoire il y a eu de la
persécution politique il y a eu tout ça
nous alors je ne comprends pas
sur quelle langue vont dire nous sommes
si sensibles sont sensibles c'est à dire
nous sommes sensibles mais nous sommes
très pragmatiques donc
nous regardez moi j'ai pas le titre
d'ambassadeur ici en France mais vous
avez dans les Grenadines c'est le
principal
non c'est à dire nous essayons quand
même nous voulons commettre comme vous
nous voulons vivre comme tous les autres
nous sommes des êtres humains
oui on est attendez je ne tombe pas dans
le piège Taïwan et un État souverain la
souveraineté one ne se décide pas aux
États-Unis ni en Allemagne et en France
ni en Chine nous avons vous savez notre
président
ce mode de raisonnement non notre
président est même plus légitime que
Monsieur sitting vient le président
chinois lui n'a jamais été élu notre
président était élu deux fois et avec un
score très confortable donc là
de je crois c'était plus de 8 millions
de voix 1% à 57 57 % dont elle a été
réélu très confortablement donc elle est
très légitime selon le fonctionnement de
de la société française de la société
européenne du monde entier donc nous
sommes très confiants de ça et nous
sommes fiers de ça on a eu un président
élu aussi très confortablement
c'est compliqué trêve de plaisanterie
selon vous
pourquoi la Chine veut Taiwan pour
contrôler le détroit de Formose
pour avoir votre PIB pour rattraper son
retard sur les semi-conducteurs par
rapport aux États-Unis pour avoir une
domination globale pour sécuriser la
Chine pourquoi elle veut Taïwan parce
que c'est super joli là-bas parce que le
climat est agréable parce qu'il y a des
montagnes pourquoi la Chine veut Taïwan
dans selon elle revenir refaire venir
Taïwan dans son giron de la mère patrie
si vous si vous écoutez
les discours de Monsieur City
vous allez voir son grand rêve c'est de
retrouver la grandeur de l'empire
chinoise mais l'Empire de quelle année
l'Empire moi je suppose de l'empire des
signes c'est la quand ils avaient plein
de territoires il veut retrouver tout ça
il estime que la Chine a des humiliée
qui
par vous par vous par la France
l'Angleterre
moi je pense le plus grave c'est pas les
Japonais je pense les tortures
et donc la Chine retrouvée son grand don
son grandeur du passé donc
ça se trouve très facilement que
Monsieur City va être le plus grand
empereur de Chine la Chine veut aussi
dominer le monde
la Chine
ne dit régulièrement que c'est leur
système communiste qui est le meilleur
système du monde et vous avez même fait
une sorte de diplomatie de masse et vous
souvenez pendant que du covid-19 en
disant ben c'est eux qui ont gagné la
guerre contre le virus des très bons
résultats aussi vous oui oui mais
justement
Taïwan et exactement le contraire de
tout ce que Monsieur sitting veut
prouver nous avons réussi à
vaincre à faire le con faire une
politique sanitaire avec la démocratie
avec la liberté avec la transparence les
confinement chez vous pas du tout pas du
tout mais jamais eu de confiance pour ça
je vous ai dit c'est-à-dire Taïwan a
très bien réussi avec la démocratie je
dis et je le redis non seulement sur la
politique sanitaire mais également
regardez maintenant pour le savoir-faire
et c'est une conducteurs nous avons nous
détenons le savoir-faire de la
fabrication des scènes conducteurs sur
l'industrie électronique sur sur plein
de choses mis à part ça Taïwan
pardonducteurs et la beauté des plages
la machine
nous pouvons presque tout faire sauf
les fusées c'est l'aérospatiale ou
[Musique]
vous par les États-Unis par tout le
monde parce qu'ils avaient peur que vous
développiez pardon qu'il fourche une
arme nucléaire on avait voulu le
construire on a voulu la voir dans c'est
votre gouvernement
avez-vous lu le faire dans les années 70
et il se retrouve à jour que le prêt le
président du plan
pour développer l'arme nucléaire était
un espion de la CIA donc il est allé il
a
dévoilé tous aux Américains sont venus
pour tout démanteler dont on avait plus
de droit donc vous savez je suis pas
pour je suis totalement pour la
dénucléarisation mais de notre côté il
faut dire le monde
ne nous aide pas pour notre défense et
nous interdit d'avoir notre façon de se
défendre
oui mais pas des armes les plus avancés
c'est quoi l'armement que vous par
exemple nous avons que le droit des F-16
on a parlé F-35 et puis c'est récent
c'est pas un bon investissement
dans le passé regardez la phrase
comme la France nous avons vendu des
miracles 2000 et des frégates après il y
avait plus il y avait plus d'occasion
encore une fois
nous remercions la France les mirages de
mire les frégates et en train de
défendre une jeune démocratie et là
c'est bien parce que c'est
ce qui concerne parce que moi je suis
pas à la France
comment vous sentez cette hypocrisie on
accepte de vous vendre des armes de
[Musique]
quand ils perçoivent ça alors je vais
d'abord vous donner une réflexion
personnelle
c'est à dire une nation ou un état juste
libre et prospère ne se construit pas
uniquement par des relations officielles
par des relations diplomatiques
donc
et puis
il y a pas d'état qui ont les conditions
pareilles pour pour se développer moi je
pense la France a vraiment de la chance
vous êtes le plus beau pays du monde
vous avez tout
la température le climat est agréable
vous n'avez pas de tremblement de terre
vous n'avez pas de temps
vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez pas de
tsunami vous n'avez pas de typhones
le climat est sec c'est très agréable de
vivre en France je crois c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle il y a tant de
tourisme et vous avez une histoire
passionnante et donc je ne peux pas
supposer je peux pas dire que Taïwan
doit aussi avoir tous ces conditions
pour être un pays un pays tout à fait
riche ou prospère donc Taïwan n'a pas
les conditions nécessaires c'est comme
ça d'ailleurs la vie aussi le monde
humaine nous ont pas tous les bonnes
conditions mais nous avons je pense nous
sommes quand même maintenant un pays qui
a bien réussi et donc nous sommes en
train de
construire
sur 7 10 à 12h par jour non non
travaillons pas comme vous vous avez un
droit du travail chez vous ah oui oui
nous avons aussi un droit de travail
chez nous donc nous sommes nous
ressemblons de plus en plus à vous à la
France
la
jeunesse aussi veut
vivre comme les Français les Français
comme comme des pays démocratiques on
veut aussi avoir beaucoup de vacances et
donc bon la vieille génération aussi
critique souvent la jeune génération je
crois ça c'est le même phénomène au
Japon ou en Corée donc nous avons pas
tous ces tous ces conditions nécessaires
mais mais nous avons réussi à construire
une démocratie
si nous sommes pas envahis par par la
Chine une démocratie quand même durable
et solide et notre économie fonctionne
bien aussi je peux vous couper oui bien
sûr
vous avez basé votre démocratie votre
pseudo souveraineté grâce moi j'appelle
ça la Suisse de l'Asie que vous avez
fait une stratégie militaire de Suisse
vous êtes boom curisé vous avez
l'équivalent des petites milices à
gauche à droite vous avez formé votre
peuple à la guérir urbaine donc prendre
une île avec une population formée à ça
c'est compliqué même quand on a l'armée
pratiquement la première armée du monde
juste derrière les États-Unis
vous avez vous tenez le monde par
[Musique]
par les semis conducteurs donc si
personne ne bouge pour vous sauver vous
allez faire quoi vous allez faire péter
votre savoir-faire non on va pas les
faire péter mais tout simplement
peut-être qu'ils vont pas laisser les
Chinois l'attraper
alors vous allez passer votre
souveraineté grâce à ça
c'est une démocratie qui peut être aussi
fragile parce que si les brevets
passe à l'ennemi ou pas dans une autre
puissance qui eux aussi se font pirater
qu'est-ce qui va se passer parce que
ça va être compliqué
votre souveraineté mise à part le fait
que vous produisiez des des supers puces
si ça ça tombe
vous retournez à votre statut de je ne
pense pas vraiment sur ce point-là
encore une fois oui oui je comprends
très bien la question je ne pense pas
que la souveraineté de Taïwan se
construit uniquement sur ce bouclier des
semi-conducteurs ce n'est
de ma part
je vous ai dit aussi j'étais professeur
des relations internationales le monde
est en train de changer le monde est
plus
ce qu'elle était avant mais aussi le
monde s'oriente vers une un mot c'était
un conflit très dangereux parce qu'il y
a deux
superpuissances qui est la Chine à
Russie qui ont déjà des territoires
immenses et qui considèrent s'ils n'ont
pas encore embouteillage plus leur
sécurité sont compromis donc la Russie a
besoin de l'Ukraine en disant s'il
c'est basé sur l'ambition de Poutine qui
pense qu'il a s'il a pas d'Ukraine la
Russie serait compromis et c'est pareil
pour Monsieur City et puis déjà c'est la
deuxième puissance économique du monde
ils ont réussi à signer un développer
mais il considère encore aussi ils n'ont
pas Taïwan et ben leur sécurité sont
compromis donc c'est c'est logique qui
est très différent de notre alors
moi-même américaine chez vous avec des
missiles on a beaucoup d'amitié la
densité des missiles à Taïwan je crois
c'est le même le plus fort du monde
entier
pour nous ce n'est pas une alors des
missiles de la défense des missiles
d'interception non pas le droit non plus
d'avoir on est très conditionné très
limité par aussi nous emmener ça à faire
mais le monde nous fait quand même une
sorte de trier des armements plus
offensifs
alors
c'était ça a été une un débat aussi au
sein mais je ne pense pas avoir de
l'armement plus offensive ce serait
mieux pour Taïwan pour nous c'est
uniquement pour se défendre parce que
une arme offensive peut faire peur à la
Chine et de les inciter à nous attaquer
donc c'est pas forcément ça qui sera
bien pour Taïwan pour nous maintenant ce
qu'on a besoin c'est bien
se défendre alors je reviens à la
question que vous posez je ne pense pas
que la sécurité
se pose uniquement sur l'industrie des
semis conducteurs moi je pense que
souvent surtout en France on me pose sur
la question est-ce que vous n'avez pas
peur d'être trahi par les Américains ou
pas même par la France et non non je
n'ai pas peur de ça parce que
la trahison se fait souvent par une
relation qui qui détient simplement deux
minorités ou de chef c'est le cas
d'Afghanistan le président l'organiste
je pense de même c'est presque un
américain il a été Président je crois de
AMF il avait été éduqué aux États-Unis
c'est comme un Américain et donc dès que
l'intérêt
n'est plus là
il est trahi je sais dans notre monde
humain une femme peut travailler un
homme un homme peut travailler une femme
si c'est ça le moment de de individus
maintenant les relations entre Taïwan et
les États-Unis avec la France c'est une
relation de deux sociétés et ça c'est
très important c'est deux démocraties de
ma part il y a il ne peut pas avoir de
trahison parce que comme c'est c'est une
masse de gens qui sont ensemble il y a
plein d'amitié il y a plein d'intérêts
donc s'il y a une partie qui dit on va
faire des choses mauvais pour ce pays-là
il y aura tout de suite immédiatement
des voies qui vont se lever ils ont ah
non non on n'est pas d'accord avec ça à
condition que ces deux sociétés sont
libres donc de ma part Taïwan et une
sorte de de société qui est complètement
adapté à au monde actuel donc il y a
plein de gens maintenant qui regardent
Taïwan d'autres choses je crois que
Taïwan la vague maintenant vous parler
de 5 candidats mais de ma part il y a
d'autres choses qui sont encore plus
importantes parce que la jeunesse plein
de gens pensent au futur le futur c'est
quoi il faut avoir un développement
durable il faut il faut penser au
changement climatique le réchauffement
de la planète et surtout la démocratie
on se questionne aussi comment la
démocratie va fonctionner en France vous
vous dites que vous avez vous avez
quelques problèmes mais au moins la
France doit être un pays démocratique
donc ce que Taïwan représente de ma part
c'est il a permis au monde de comprendre
que le les sociétés cynophones ont aussi
une autre alternative c'est-à-dire le
monde sinophone peut bien vivre avec des
valeurs universelles et ça c'est très
très important parce que si tu as
disparaisse le monde sinophone va rester
chien en consévise plus la démocratie et
uniquement le système autoritaire de la
Chine et de toute façon après vous allez
vous vous rendez vers un conflit avec la
Chine et ça c'est un conflit à long
terme donc de ma part
non parce que parce que Taïwan avec la
Chine oui mais il y a encore quelque
chose qui détient dans ce que je veux
dire encore Taïwan est en train de aussi
donner des des messages au peuple
chinois mais regardez on peut bien vivre
avec la liberté la démocratie et ça
c'est il y a une importance extrême là
dessus le rôle que taïwaju donc si nous
regardons sur ce point là la
souveraineté one ou
l'autonomie de Taïwan se pose sur
beaucoup sur beaucoup de niveaux c'est
beaucoup de domaines pas simplement sur
les industries et c'est là que nous
avons confiance parce que nous avons
trouvé encore une fois que la démocratie
ça fonctionne chez nous nous avons
existé je crois par une attitude qui
mesurait les la maturité des démocratie
le 8e la 8e démontre je crois c'est déjà
il crée d'un mix
britannique on est là le huitième
démocratie le plus le plus mûr du monde
même mieux que la France ou l'Allemagne
ou les États-Unis les pays qui sont
devant nous sont les pays de l'Europe du
Nord des pays nordiques donc je pense
c'est ça que nous travaillons beaucoup
et que j'ai confiance que Taïwan pourra
continuer à bien survivre quel rapport
vous entretenez avec les autres pays
d'Asie du Sud-Est alors là tout le monde
a peur la Chine donc le pays qu'on a le
meilleur les meilleures relations ça
doit être au Japon c'est le Japon je
crois même presque le seul pays qui
ose à nous soutenir sur
les discours sur les déclarations sur le
plan politique regardez hier il y a eu
la conférence de plus de entre la France
et le Japon c'est-à-dire ministre de des
Affaires étrangères ministre de la
Défense et bien il y a un gros
paragraphe qui dit que
la sécurité et la stabilité du détroit
de Taïwan et indispensable pour la
prospérer du monde
à dire ça vous avez une ambassade au
Japon
non non non non
ambassadeur au Japon c'est comme moi ici
en France nous sommes représentants et
puis d'ailleurs Taïwan ce mot là c'est
aussi un tabou vous savez sur les 118
Missions Étrangères de Town dans le
monde je crois pour moi il y a un seul
qui a le mot Taïwan mais qui en plus
c'est même pas le nom Taïwan c'est en
Lituanie c'est la représentation
taïwanais c'est un adjectif dans tous
les autres pays c'est moi je suis
représentant de Taipei en France et au
Japon c'est pareil
vous leviez pour développer des rapports
plus profonds et que les autres pays
mis à part le fait de dire que si Taïwan
s'effondre c'est compliqué pour vos
valeurs démocratiques vous avez d'autres
leviers ou pas oui alors regardez
maintenant je vais essayer de le dire ça
parce que je crois que cette question-là
je vous avais un peu expliqué là
maintenant si tu as séparé de la Chine
tout le monde vit bien vous travaillez
avec nous on travaille ce que 5000
onduiteurs nous travaillons sur sur
beaucoup de valeurs nous travaillons
pour la regarder pour la critique covid
19 Taïwan a été le premier pays à donner
l'alerte mais simplement ça n'a pas été
accepté par l'OMS nous avons voulu nous
avons aussi à l'époque je crois c'était
en 2020 en mois de mars nous avons donné
plusieurs plusieurs millions de masses
dans le monde entier en France nous
avons donné un million de masques qui a
été transféré à la Croix-Rouge et 1500
frontières donc tout va bien alors si
jamais la Chine arrive à conquérir
Taïwan déjà je sais pas si le monde peut
accepter et bien que la Chine détient
bon ce qu'on vient de dire le savoir
faire des cellules candidats mais l'osso
c'est de la Chine domine le pas de
l'océan Pacifique et là je trouve c'est
le système autorité qui est la plus
efficace donc sur tous ces choses-là
Taïwan d'ailleurs a été aussi le premier
pays qui avait autorisé le mariage pour
tous faire disparaître donc
je ne sais pas si le monde est prêt à
accepter un monde fait par cette
conséquence de la disparition de Taïwan
dans dans le monde vous y préparez un
peu au fait
que la Chine puisse envahir par les
ports du Sud ou que la Chine par exemple
là récemment donc dans un journal
télévisé chinois il montrait des
manœuvres pour prendre Taïwan ça
commencerait par des bombardements
depuis des bateaux depuis le la Chine
continentale ça fait quel effet écoutez
nous sommes habitués par la menace par
la menace chinoise depuis
70 ans
alors ce qui change c'est c'est la
capacité militaire de la Chine qui a été
qui a été vraiment qui a fait un grand
progrès sous monsieur 6e ville
la guerre
à Taïwan personne ne veut la guerre
parce que nous sommes nous vivons libre
nous sommes bien nous entendons avec
vous les Francs la France la France les
États-Unis est le Japon et pendant
certains moments nous avons aussi
beaucoup de relations commerciales avec
la Chine donc personne interne à la
guerre mais personne ne peut prédire
on n'est pas dans la pensée de Monsieur
City le président chinois donc tout ce
que nous devons faire c'est de se
préparer
et donc par exemple Taïwan a été aussi
très naïve donc n'avons supprimé le
service militaire il y a quelques années
moi-même j'avais fait la sanitaire de
deux ans moi je suis dans les petites
îles très près de la Chine vous étiez
dans un bureau vous crapaille utile avec
un sac à dos
[Musique]
et donc
l'armée c'est-à-dire essaie aussi de se
renforcer nous nous sommes aussi en
train de décès de construire notre
propre sous-marin parce que avant nous
n'avons pas le savoir-faire et puis
personne ne voulait nous transférer le
serveur de la conscience des sous-marins
et les sous-marins et ça nous permet
aussi de de
débloquer si jamais il y a un blocus
fait par la Chine nous renforcerons
aussi nous essayons de moderniser notre
notre Armée de l'Air notre notre flotte
maritime tout ça donc ce sont les
préparations qui sont en train de faire
mais bien sûr donc vous faites vous
faites de
vous cherchez des portes de sortie en
termes d'armement parce que personne
veut vous vendre des technologies clés
je pense il y a de l'aide américaine
absurde là-dessus ils nous vend pas les
essayer de transférer certains
savoir-faire est-ce que j'ai pas spécial
là-dedans je pense ça doit le cas vous
devez vous venez nous donner une super
information non c'est pas super
informations tout le monde sait parce
que il y a une autre information c'est à
dire avant vous savez il y a des choses
qui ont vraiment changé les Chinois
considérés il y a encore trois ans ou 4
ans que si jamais il y a une présence
militaire étrangère à Taïwan sera
considéré comme une déclaration de
guerre contre la Chine et vous savez
maintenant il y a 200 militaires
américains qui sont sur place qui sont
en train d'entraîner nos armées donc il
y a des choses qui ont changé et même
quand je parlais de la visite de Nancy
pellossi qui est devenue dans un avion
spécial de américaines d'armée
américaine et ben c'est pareil pour dans
le passé c'était considéré comme par la
Chine comme une dégration de guerre ce
qui est le plus amusant c'était pas si
le mot amusant et non mais oui je crois
j'ai mal utilisé le terme je crois ce
qui est merci de m'avoir
rappeler ça ce qui est le plus ce qu'ils
ont rassuré c'est je crois ça être en
2021 je vous disais en 2020 nous avons
très bien fait la gestion du covid 19
mais pendant un moment il nous manquait
des vaccins et la Chine a fait pression
partout dans le monde pour que le monde
ne pouvait pas nous vendre vaccins et
par exemple Pfizer nous avait promis
parce que moi j'étais vraiment là-dedans
d'un premier je crois que le million
vaccin
en 2021 que je sais plus quel mois et
ils ont annulé à la veille d'avoir de
ces vaccins parce que la Chine ça fait
pression
et donc nous nous étions dans une
station pas facile il y avait pas de
covid mais non plus pas de vaccin il va
nous savons très bien qu'il faut qu'il
faut des vaccins et donc
moi aussi j'étais demandé par par
monument pour voir si la France pouvait
nous vendre des vaccins bon la réponse
est négatif et donc je crois le 4 juin
alors le 4 juin c'est déjà
vous savez le 4 juin c'est le massacre
les Japonais ont annoncé qu'il a donc
donné plusieurs millions de vaccins je
crois après c'était le 6 juin le jour de
de
du débarquement et bah les organes
plusieurs sénateurs américains sont
venus avec un gros porteur militaire
américain pour amener des vaccins à
Taïwan c'était une aide américaine donc
tout ça il y avait des tabous qui ont
été qui ont été changé
les dernières années donc pour vous dire
que des choses évoluent les choses
évoluent et puis nous nous espérons bien
sûr travailler avec tout le monde de
résoudre cette menace chinoise qui de ma
part
n'est pas simplement ne peut de ne pas
être résout résoudre ne pas être
résoudre c'est-à-dire à ne pas résolu
uniquement par des moyens militaires il
faut qu'on travaille ensemble pour que
la paix soit maintenue et il faut pas
toujours penser que le conflit militaire
et le seul issu
est-ce que vous faites du renseignement
économique à
taïwanes dans vos semi-conducteur pour
pouvoir les j'étais en train de français
renseignements économique ça peut
exister dans dans chez les industriels
mais non à ma connaissance par le groupe
qui est des espions à Taïwan qui se
projettent à l'international
est-ce que vous avez un service de
sécurité intérieure de sécurité mais je
ne pense pas que nous avons pas
d'ambition géopolitique ça sert pas à
grand chose d'avoir des espions
surveiller vos usines que vous projetez
par exemple au Texas où en Allemagne
je ne pense pas parce que déjà l'usine
que nous que nous allons construire au
Texas dater CMC d'abord il faut bien
être conscience ce n'est pas une usine
nationale du gouvernement de Taïwan
c'est une usine privée donc il y a des
intérêts c'est pour ça que ça les a
poussés à s'installer aux États-Unis
pris l'énergie là c'était le prix de
l'énergie prix d'énergie l'eau aussi
territoire vous savez
si nous regardons
et aussi la demande des puces va
exploser d'une façon exponentielle tout
devient électrique donc
TMC pour maintenir sa domination dans la
production et aussi obligé le travailler
avec avec vous avec la France avec
l'Allemagne avec le Japon avec avec les
États-Unis et donc c'est aussi des
intérêts économiques qui les a poussés à
cette aux États-Unis avec une toute
petite production une toute petite oui
pour le moment parce que c'est une
production de sauvegarde c'est une
production de sauvegarde en cas de
guerre avec la Chine
alors peut-être peut-être mais ce que je
dois vous dire c'est que
pour produire des puces ce n'est pas si
simple c'est pas comme le gaz nous avons
des problèmes de gaz d'énergie avec
l'Ukraine et donc en France nous les
achetons d'Algérie pour pour vraiment
faire sortir aux États-Unis je sais je
sais mais ça veut dire ça peut se faire
dans un an ou sinon on achète un an
peut-être un jour non peut-être ça peut
se changer
immédiatement dans quelques mois vous
savez la production des puces ça c'est
pas comme ça on installe une usine et
puis l'année prochaine on aura tous les
semis conducteurs il y a un écosystème
il y a aussi une sorte de précision
alors des gens aussi oublient les
semi-conducteurs c'est aussi une
production des pays démocratiques en
général le design se fait aux États-Unis
en Europe après on est fait produire à
Taïwan mais avant ça il y a des machines
qui sont monopolisées unique enfin
qu'ils ont produit par les Hollandais
donc c'est qui monopolise tout ça et
après quand l'usine de Taïwan produit et
ses cinq moniteur on a besoin des
produits chimiques maintenant de base
allemand Air Liquide français pour
finalement de faire sortir donc c'est
vous regardez tous cette chaîne
production sont des pays démocratiques
donc de ma part je pense et important
que le monde sache le processus de tout
ça et pour dire bah quand on nous
installé une usine aux États-Unis au
Japon c'est aussi à la demande du marché
qui en a besoin
en 2021 Taiwan a une grosse sécheresse
non
oui certainement j'étais pas Taïwan
est-ce que c'est un menacé le
fonctionnement de TMC
non oui ça a menacé mais comme le
gouvernement Taïwan met en priorité
aussi la TMC je crois je crois sur ce
point-là à Taïwan il y a aussi un débat
donc parce qu'on privilège les grandes
entreprises merci excusez-moi les
grandes entreprises et bien sûr au
détriment des habitants de l'agriculture
ou des habitants ou des ça peut se
produire donc tout ça ce n'est pas si
simple que ça et ça peut aussi d'un côté
il y a assez que les nationales mais le
côté il y a aussi le sentiment de la
population et donc par exemple en
2023 2022 le gouvernement le parti au
pouvoir encore perdu de gros l'élection
régionale pour des raisons économiques
dans tout ça c'est pas facile
comment le pays se prépare au
préchauffement climatique parce que
produire des puces à consommer moins
énormément d'eau du nom de qualité on
peut pas faire ça avec de l'eau de mer
vous avez pas trop d'énergie chez vous
vous l'avez abandonné le nucléaire bon
l'éolien c'est un peu intermittent les
capacités de stockage vous avez
peut-être des montagnes oui ça peut vous
aider à stocker de l'énergie peut-être
comment comment le pays se prépare au
réchauffement climatique
un taux d'humidité dramatique avec une
température qui augmente
installer des clims quand on a pas de
réacteur nucléaire quand on habite un
pays substropical c'est compliqué ça
devient vraiment invivable
quand vous y préparez
nous essayons comme tout le monde de
limiter un peu par exemple chez nous
c'est la consommation de du clim donc on
dit qu'il faut pas mettre plus bas que
25 degrés
nous y préparons et puis il y a des
choses par exemple il y a de plus en
plus de on a on a plus besoin de mettre
notre costume quand on va dans des dans
des réunions formelles en disant ça ça
regardez et là on est à 13 14 18 degrés
on peut en remettre le costume mais à 30
degrés ça va être difficile on essaie
aussi de changer aussi la façon que nous
nous habillons nous essayons aussi par
exemple nous avons le vélo libre à
Taïwan d'ailleurs qu'on a appris de
France qui est maintenant qui fonctionne
très bien même je pense mieux que qu'en
France
nous nous limitons aussi
dire l'utilisation des des voitures
particuliers nous les encourageons de
prendre des des transports publics
un prix pas cher c'est subventionné le
métro à Taïwan est vraiment pas cher du
tout le ticket de métro à Taïwan
c'est ça commence par
je crois 70 centimes sans 10 centimes le
trajet pour le métro donc c'est à la
station c'est commencer
je crois c'est la distance c'est à
distance et après ça peut aller le plus
cher de métro qui est maintenant qui
fonctionne bien ça doit être simplement
c'est à la distance la plus loin ça doit
être à peu près 2 euros 2 euros
je crois
c'est quand même 40 à 50 km donc c'est
pas une distance de très très courte il
faut quand même 40 minutes à une heure
donc nous encourageons beaucoup vraiment
le vélo tout ça et voilà donc la façon
que nous nous préparons aussi ne sont
pas tellement différents
mais nous avons encore besoin de
beaucoup plus d'échanges avec vous ce
que Taïwan maintenant demande d'ailleurs
je me permets de vraiment d'accéder
là-dessus c'est vraiment que quand le
monde regarde Taïwan quand nous avons
aussi besoin de discussions pour faire
progresser le pays pour faire que pour
non seulement nous sommes nous sommes là
pour montrer qu'on est capable de
contribuer c'est aussi maintenant
l'augmenter mais aussi on a besoin de
discuter avec vous sur des sujets
concrets et il faut
il faut pas seulement laisser la Chine
vous imposer qu'elle a mis vous pouvez
choisir discuter à Taïwan pour nous
c'est
responsable sur beaucoup de sujets sur
la santé publique sur ont épouser
beaucoup de questions sur l'énergie tout
ça parce que sur tous ces questions là
nous sommes très souvent refusés par
exemple si je me je reviens maintenant
en ce moment bientôt c'est c'est
l'assemblée Gérald de Metz c'est de la
100 le 11e mondiale de la santé
là-dedans pour pour discuter normalement
avec les autres pays c'est normal
organisation
on n'a pas de statut et pourquoi ça
empêche un échange entre deux êtres
humains
vous voyez donc c'est ça que je regrette
beaucoup
tous ces intuitions du système d'eau
nuit au début et de basé sur des valeurs
universelles qu'il fallait mettre tout
le monde dedans au moins pour permettre
à plus d'échanges qu'on avance ensemble
mais maintenant tous ces institutions
maintenant vous savez Interpol
tellement peur même refuse de quand on
veut leur transmettre à une lettre ils
ont tellement peur qu'il veut pas nous
voir et donc c'est très très politisé
tout ça donc tout ce que Taïwan souhaite
pour le moment c'est que nous pouvons
nous rencontrer normalement discuter des
choses concrètes des formations
si c'est d'accord d'accord de façon
informelle aussi pour nous mais au moins
par exemple notre président pourquoi il
ne peut pas aller normalement en or en
Europe parce que vous voyez c'est une
question de passeport c'est une question
de vol commercial c'est une question je
fais une question de politique ou même
si physiquement il peut pas venir au
moins un qui peut discuter avec avec
vous par téléphone pour discuter les
sujets donc moi moi je pense et c'est
très important c'est ce que Taïwan a
besoin et c'est une liste de cette
façon-là qu'on va construire notre futur
ensemble comment vous protéger de
l'ingérence vous m'avez parlé du fait
que en 19 70 Taïwan avait un programme
nucléaire
défensif
vous êtes fait un petit peu carotté par
un espion américain
vous l'avez jugé le gars où il est
planqué aux États-Unis
après vous savez vous avez son nom
je sais plus d'un coup
vous protégez des ingérences que ce soit
américain chinoises russes françaises
allemandes ou Papou comment vous votre
service intérieur parce que comment ça
se passe vous avez une surveillance de
masse non nous n'avons pas ça et puis ça
au feeling vous faites parce que pour
l'instant vous êtes encore les leaders
ça va peut-être pas durer longtemps non
on n'est pas leader du tout pour les
endurance étrangères nous je pense c'est
quand même Taïwan un beau petit pot de
miel au milieu de tous ces requins
non oui oui
position technologique clé
démocratiquement parlant vous emmerdez
un peu tout le monde c'est un peu la
Suisse mais c'est le fromage vous êtes
libre
mais comment intérieurement vous
protéger des ingérences de la
ce qui est précieux nous utilisons pas
cela comme une sorte de à une sorte de
pour marcher en dés pour dire si vous
faites pas ceci nous faisons pas cela
parce que nous savons très bien que si
nous faisons cela après ça peut aussi
être abandonné par le monde
vraiment je ne pense pas que maintenant
nous le faisons très bien nous avons des
savoir-faire par exemple
si je viens de chiffre en tête tous les
jours nous subissons un million
d'attaques
cyber de
venant du monde entier qui est
essentiellement chinois alors la France
j'espère quand même non mince alors
est servie comme une base par les autres
pour attaquer mais je ne suis pas du
tout moi je dis n'importe quoi parce que
je suis pas spécial là dedans mais je
sais qu'il y a un million d'attaques
tous les jours alors nous pouvons nous
avons les moyens ou je crois nous
pourrons échanger comment nous
travaillons ensemble je ne suis pas sûr
que nous nous cédons
à tous les savoir-faire alors sur les
autres ingérences qui n'est pas
uniquement sur ces moyens de cyber ça
peut être aussi sur les moyens
économiques politiques tout ça je crois
on est quand même mauvais c'est
la démocratie de Taïwan maintenant
aussi
c'est à dire je disais d'un côté solide
qu'on veut le garder mais de l'autre
côté vous regardez les sujets qu'on
discute à terme il y a des fois comment
tout ça peut se produire à Taïwan donc
ces ingériens parce que la Chine a quand
même réussi à mettre en place à Taïwan
leur agence et sur ce point là vous
savez de t'avoir dit aussi un problème
c'est-à-dire notre
identité de renseignements oui de tout
vous savez à Taïwan nous avons
ils ont réussi
il faut il faut regarder aussi comme
vous savez comme notre
identité nationale parce que je voulais
parler tout à l'heure que il y a
beaucoup de on avait parlé de parler
plein de choses vous savez à l'intérieur
de Taïwan cette identité nationale n'est
pas basée comme en France sur l'histoire
sur l'ADN sur
en France mais dans certains pays
c'est-à-dire que vous descendez de même
peuple même vraiment la même nation
c'est pas alors je crois j'ai mal
utilisé la France comme ça parce que la
France je sais que vous êtes c'est la
richesse de la France tu as aussi essayé
de trouver cette richesse mais par
exemple la Chine A6 beaucoup sur vous
savez quand je compare ou la Corée ou le
Japon ils sont ils sont plutôt ils sont
pas si si vous avez aussi
je décide le mot c'est à dire qui a qui
a beaucoup de d'étrangers qui sont venus
chez eux pour vivre alors à Taïwan il y
a pas ça
oui je pense oui je pense
[Musique]
les aborigènes les Noirs
alors par exemple
c'est-à-dire parce que notre
gouvernement pour corriger ce passé pour
corriger tout ça moi j'utilise corrigé
nous avons une chaîne publique pour pour
la culture des abrogènes nous avons même
un ministère chargé uniquement pour les
affaires des abrogènes pour essayer de
trouver un peu plus de justice
avec des arbresiens qui étaient des
vrais les vrais taïwanais sur place nous
avons même des sièges au sein du
Parlement qui sont garantis pour les
abrogènes par exemple vous avez 12 14
tribus local
le gouvernement leur donne un petit peu
une compensation du fait que vous voulez
vous avez piqué l'île ou pas du tout la
compensation se fait sur je vous ai dit
sur par exemple la garantie de leurs
droits politiques
aussi quand une langue officielle
nous avons si vous voulez une seule
entier qui est le mandarin il y a le
taïwanais le temps est qui est parlé le
haka et puis tous les langues aborigènes
et maintenant de plus en plus aussi de
langue venant de la ligne du Sud-Est
voilà donc
vous êtes aux abrogène oui c'est
d'ailleurs nous nous essayons de
corriger ce
passé
que
donc notre président ne s'est excusé
devant les aborigènes de de c'est à dire
des crimes si vous voulez aussi mais des
erreurs tout ça qu'on avait fait sur eux
qu'on les a fait subir dans quand les
Hans de Chine sont venus s'installer à
Taïwan et donc oui
de tout ça donc voyez Taïwan fait
beaucoup de d'efforts pour essayer de
d'améliorer tout ça et après j'ai oublié
votre question au début revenons aux
ingérences ah oui les ingérences donc
pour les je parlais oui je parlais de
l'identité nationale de Taïwan ne se
fait pas sur normalement ce que vous
regardez au Japon en Corée en France il
se fait maintenant de ma part quand je
garde plutôt sur des valeurs
universelles c'est-à-dire on n'est pas
d'accord sur
vous êtes quand même beaucoup plus c'est
vous avez votre histoire commune tout ça
nous n'avons beaucoup moins l'histoire
Taïwan
écrit et simplement de 400 ans et
d'ailleurs sur la façon par exemple que
je venais de vous expliquer à l'histoire
Taïwan je pense à Taïwan il y a des gens
qui vont se dire ah non non on n'est pas
d'accord avec avec moi donc je crois ce
qui nous met vraiment en commun comme
identité nationale c'est la démocratie
de la liberté et donc ce qui fait que
l'ingérence de la Chine de vouloir
mettre ta voix vraiment du côté chinois
de
discuter avec le narratif chinois
çaïwan c'est une question à vous poser
vous êtes représentant de taiper
représentant de Taïwan ambassadeur de
Taïwan je sais pas comment il faut vous
appeler
est-ce que vous représentez en tant que
diplomate
les gens qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
le fait de rester taïwanais est-ce qu'il
y a il y a combien de pourcentage de
gens à Taïwan qui sont pour le
rattachement avec la Chine continentale
là je suis très sûr c'est à dire il n'y
a que je crois 4% des gens à Taïwan qui
sont pour le rattachement avec la Chine
là c'est vraiment ils sont qui cultivent
et qui s'occupe de de Chanca échec
est-ce que c'est des pros de gens Cachi
les prochains échecs sont nettement plus
nombreux proches pas forcément dire
procine parce qu'il faut savoir que tu
as un check quand il est venu
c'était c'était l'ennemi juré de mars et
donc qui combattait vraiment avec tous
ces forces les commissions
ça veut dire quoi votre drapeau
alors le drapeau vous voyez
c'est à dire le vous voyez un peu le
travaux s'il y a le rouge et en dessous
il y a une sorte de soleil donc c'est
oui sur fond bleu oui donc
c'est le soleil qui
brille dans dans la terre alors mais le
soleil là c'est aussi le symbole du KMT
donc notre drapeau qui veut dire pour le
parti d'opposition le parti notre
drapeau national est complètement lié
avec l'histoire de du CMD donc souvent
le problème que nous avons dans le passé
c'est de partir et l'État forment la
même chose donc tout ce qui est symbole
maintenant de l'armée de la police de
tous les ministères sont encore liés
avec le KMT et nous ne pouvons pas
changer ça
pour le moment parce que si on change de
ça déjà il y a une opposition à
l'intérieur et il y a aussi
la Chine qui nous pression et puis il y
a aussi la communauté la communauté
internationale je pense et aussi
là-dedans elle veut pas que Taïwan joue
quoi que ce soit pour ce qu'on appelle
ce qu'on appelle soi-disant provoquer la
Chine la Chine dit que la population de
Taïwan refuse le rattachement parce que
la population de Taïwan subit de la
propagande étant doctriner vers un seul
courant et que c'est pour ça je sais
qu'il y a dit ça
et donc qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que
vous quel est votre analyse de ça non
déjà
les gens qui c'est l'ambassadeur de
chinois en France Monsieur Louchard qui
avait dit ça
je crois il n'a jamais été à Taïwan
et donc c'est c'est le résultat
c'est d'un peuple qui veut la liberté
qui veut la démocratie et qui voit quand
on devenus très différents de la Chine
donc c'est pas une question de ce qu'il
avait dit parce que les gens à Taïwan je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure que les
Taïwanais de cette façon représente une
alternative du monde sinophone donc il y
a des gens qui se considèrent
parce que sinon vous savez dans notre
langue il y a le monde cynophones il y a
le mot chinois ça fait ça fait très très
c'est vendu à la Chine alors nous avons
un autre mot qui voulait dire des gens
qui parlent chinois le roi donc là on
peut mettre Singapour on peine aussi
certains des gens qui vivent en Asie du
Sud-Est et je crois joue un modèle pour
tous ces gens qui parlent encore le
chinois et ça c'est très très important
parce que qu'on a le goût de la liberté
on veut on veut la voir vous savez
récemment l'étymologie de ce mot que
j'ai compris l'équivalent
d'une certaine façon nous on a un
francophone
c'est à peu près la francophonie merci
merci de m'avoir rappelé ou les
Anglo-Saxons si vous voulez ça ressemble
à ça donc
il n'y a pas de mots en français ni en
anglais simplement pour dire le mot il y
a le monde cylophone donc vous savez
récemment
je crois je l'ai dû ce matin que les
Chinois qui maintenant qui essaient
d'immigrer vers les États-Unis
illégalement ont augmenté de 15 fois de
plus que l'année dernière où il y a deux
ans
alors je crois cette année c'est l'année
c'est à peu près les 10000 qui sont qui
sont qui sont qui sont passés par
l'Amérique du Sud et qui ont pris la
voie des mises à jour illégales pour
aller aux États-Unis donc voyez les
Chinois
vous avez interview monsieur l'ambassade
de luchaille et qui dit tout est la
faute des États-Unis mais regardez tous
ces chinois qui veut aller vivre ça
selon vous
je ne connais pas je n'ai jamais parlé
avec lui si j'organise un apéro je serai
content je serai ravi de discuter avec
lui si vous réussissez
ravi mais je doute que vous allez
réussir à nous mettre ensemble sur la
même pièce moi je vais pas peur mais lui
certainement il va dire non non c'est
pas possible donc pour vous dire que la
liberté la démocratie c'est quelque
chose qui qui nous différencie beaucoup
beaucoup de la Chine pourquoi
selon vous c'est toujours la faute des
États-Unis pour la Chine
c'est une façon de créer une sorte de
d'ennemis et de rassembler une Chine qui
a plein de problèmes à l'intérieur ce
sont c'est toujours la faute de la Chine
et c'est
un phénomène qui en disant c'est
toujours il faut des Américains qui
pouvons vraiment faire encore
c'est-à-dire faire monter ce
nationalisme pour moi qui est devenu
très très dangereux
je pense c'est le problème des systèmes
autoritaires dans pendant 20 ans 30 ans
nous avons cru que nous pouvons partager
certains futurs avec tous ces systèmes
autoritaires et je pense qu'on a eu tort
la Chine maintenant a un gros problème
c'est à dire il mit tout leur futur sur
la grande machine mais s'il y a plus ce
monde a il y aura plus de la chaîne que
ça sert parce que le monde sera détruit
c'est un gros problème que je pense que
la Chine n'a pas encore réfléchi et puis
comme ils n'ont pas la liberté de
réfléchir ils n'ont pas la liberté de de
d'exprimer des idées différentes ce que
je crains beaucoup et donc il va falloir
que nous on travaille ensemble pour en
tant que taïwanais
qui avait connu une dictature
une loi martiale
quel est votre point de vue sur
giulianassonge et Edward Snowden
celui qui avait vendu les
personnes n'a rien vendu dans cette
histoire
alors vous faire des copains aux
États-Unis en répondant à cette question
non je
ne pense pas alors j'ai commençons par
Julian Assange qui est dans un quartier
de haute sécurité en Angleterre
compliqué les États-Unis demandent sont
extradition
Julian Assange pour vous
c'est un prisonnier politique
c'est un journaliste en prison c'est un
espion c'est pas un espion
comment vous percevez déjà Julien
Assange après on passera Edward Snowden
alors les deux pour moi ça va pas déjà
je reconnais parce que je n'ai pas
beaucoup
étudié c'est une réponse de diplomate
non c'est aussi je le dis franchement
parce que je ne peux pas tout savoir
pour moi ce qui me concerne le plus
c'est vraiment
et j'aime pas ça non je suis pas
d'accord parce que nous sommes en train
de faire face aussi à des problèmes à
l'intérieur de Taïwan c'est à dire que
vous avez regardez
des lanceurs d'alerte quand Giuliana
songe publie la vidéo collatérale des
mecs sur un massacre américain sur un
caméraman qui avait rien demandé à quoi
que ce soit qui s'est fait foudroyer
avec ses copains et où ils sont plantés
quand on voit Edward Snowden qui qui est
un lanceur d'alerte qui dit voilà les
États-Unis écoutent leur population
écoute des chefs d'État la France
l'Allemagne les ministres le lin plus de
plus 3
c'est un lanceur d'alerte c'est pas un
lanceur d'alerte c'est un traître c'est
pas un traître pour vous c'est quoi et
l'autre question les lanceurs d'alerte à
Taïwan ont-ils
un statut de protection particulière ou
pas je peux vous dire quand Taïwan il y
a plein de lanceurs d'alerte quel était
la grosse affaire la dernière à Taïwan
qu'il était le plus gros lanceur
d'alerte récemment à Taïwan
mais vous avez cru que vous avez venu
ici pour pousser un caddie ou quoi non
non mais ce que vous savez là à Taïwan
par exemple nous j'ai été nous avons été
obligés de faire face à des gens qui dit
que par exemple notre présidente avait
avait
pas vraiment son degré de doctorat que
c'était qu'il avait elle avait copié on
avait on n'arrivait pas à trouver
ce qu'elle avait vraiment écrit que
c'était vrai elle avait fait le LCI
c'est London c'est
l'école économique de Londres qui est le
plus connu
l'école a dit que non madame la
Présidente votre thèse est vrai et tout
avait il y a aucun problème vous avez
vraiment le degré de doctorat mais des
hathawa il y a plein de continuer à
l'attaquer et même entrer dans la
justice c'est peut-être des Chinois
derrière non non non oui peut-être
peut-être mais je vais dire
[Musique]
parce que sinon notre pays est
immédiatement en danger et donc je peux
pas résoudre non plus vos problèmes de
retraits en France donner une opinion
moi j'ai pas d'opinion vous savez et
donc sur cette sur certains sujets vous
pouvez vous exprimer ou pas parce que
vraiment c'était vraiment des histoires
que moi-même je n'ai pas des éléments
suffisants vous m'avez dit oui c'est
lanceur en principe je suis d'accord
mais je suis pas suffisant informé ou je
n'ai pas d'éléments suffisant pour
donner mon opinion là-dessus question
Internet le Burkina Faso pays d'Afrique
de l'Ouest merci c'est sympa Justino ah
rompu ses relations diplomatiques avec
Taiwan pour des raisons certainement
stratégiques cette vague de rupture ne
légitime-t-elle pas la position de la
Chine vis-à-vis de Taïwan que fait
Taïwan pour préserver ses relations avec
les autres États africains face à une
Chine pleinement plébiscité en Afrique
alors de ma part je crois tous ces pays
là ont droit de choisir leur destin donc
dans le passé
je crois je peux dire que nous les avons
beaucoup aidés par exemple pour pour
l'industrie du riz tout ça pour aussi
pour beaucoup d'infrastructures
souvent en Taïwan quand nous maintenant
nos relations avec ces pays-là la seule
chose que nous demandons c'est que nous
maintenant une relation normale que vous
ne reconnaissez et puis que vous nous
soutenez de temps en temps au sein des
Nations Unies tout ça alors ils ont
décidé parce que je ne pense pas ces
gens pour des raisons stratégiques mais
pour des raisons financières ils ont
décidé d'arrêter de relation dépendus
avec Taïwan et d'aller vers la Chine je
crois je respecte leur décision et puis
je vous ai dit dès le début que Taiwan
maintenant
nous avons créé une sorte de modèle que
la survie de notre pays ne se construit
pas uniquement avec des relations
officielles et d'ailleurs maintenant
nous avons 13 si ça continue à avoir des
problèmes nous avons aussi des moyens
après de les maintenir
parce que nous avons aussi besoin d'un
certain reconnaissance mais pour le
moment nous avons décidé de suivre vous
savez si nous mettons aussi déjà on aura
du mal à voir l'accord de l'assemblée
nationale pour continuer à maintenir
cette démocratie de chèque blanc ou
d'avant alors même si on en est mettons
vous savez selon vos
OCDE
votre valeur tout ce que vous essayez de
mettre mieux cette communauté
internationale si vous mettez de
l'argent là-dessus vous avez aussi à
payer corrompu vous savez que je veux
dire c'est aussi contraire des valeurs
que nous voulons travailler avec des
États-Unis avec la France où ça avec les
avec Batman donc pour le moment je pense
c'est le choix du Burkina Faso donc
simplement nous n'y pouvons rien et puis
en étant un pays libre on n'auront plus
tous ces moyens là de maintenir ce que
l'on fait avec eux dans le passé
question Internet les
îles de qui mène qui mène Matsu book you
se trouve très très d'écoute tout à fait
moi j'ai fait mon service militaire
là-bas
quelle est leur situation
quelles sont leurs positions vis-à-vis
de cette situation de guerre imminente
souhaite-t-il se rattacher au continent
alors ça c'est
d'ailleurs ils sont tellement près de la
Chine que
pour le moment au niveau du
développement enfin de développement
économique
il dépend plus
la Chine que Taïwan mais de l'autre côté
il aussi il préfère la liberté la
démocratie à Taïwan donc pour le moment
ce sont des endroits où
d'un côté il souhaite que Taïwan puisse
trouver un moyen
pacifique avec la Chine
qui leur permet d'avoir de garantir leur
prospérité économique mais de l'autre
côté je ne pense pas qu'il souhaite un
rattachement avec la Chine parce que
comme je vous ai dit tout la démocratie
la liberté c'est le plus grand consensus
au sein de Taïwan
si la Chine devenait démocratique Taïwan
envisagerait-elle une réunion avec la
Chine non non pas du tout je ne pense
pas du tout
je crois on est on est entré cette phase
là est déjà passé que les Taïwanais ne
considère plus du tout chinois donc pour
déjà la démocratie pour la majeure
partie selon vous oui pour la majorité
déjà en attendant la démocratie de la
Chine je ne sais pas il faut attendre
combien d'années et quand si en espérant
qu'il y aura ce jour-là Taïwan aura
passé encore une génération suivante et
nous savons très bien si vous regardez
ce qui se passe à Taïwan les générations
qui arrivent
qui sont la jeune génération la jeunesse
taïwanais c'est vraiment la génération
qui s'oppose le plus à cette
cette identité chinoise donc moi je ne
pense pas du tout que ça va arriver et
puis pourquoi toujours attaché à un
grand empire je ne vois pas la raison si
si ça c'est faisable des Belges aurait
dû aussi fallu les Wallons réduit
justement des rattachement avec la
France
bon c'est important de la bonne humeur
vous connaissez la Wallonie oui je
connais bien la Wallonie extraordinaire
j'aime bien les Belges d'ailleurs
j'avais vécu aussi certains moments en
Belgique
à Louvain à Louvain-la-Neuve
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du Crédit
Social chinois
vous me posez beaucoup de questions en
Chine moi je trouve
c'est vraiment c'est triste pour eux
pourquoi
ça permet ça permet peut-être d'éduquer
une population qui chiffre en milliards
et en parfait état et qu'il y a vraiment
pas de d'ingérence politique partout par
tout simplement parce que vous avez une
opinion différente de nous et on vous
met en rouge
donc moi je suis et je crois c'est une
façon
pour permettre au gouver en chinois de
encore mieux contrôler la population dès
que ce que j'ai entendu dire bien sûr il
y a ce côté là qui force la
Chine à être ce qu'on appelle des
Chinois civilisés mais c'est aussi ça
permet aussi à contrôler à verrouiller
tout ce qui s'oppose aux politiques du
mouvement chinois et c'est ça qui est
très triste ça devient prison est-ce que
vous inspirez un peu de la Chine de
temps en temps
je crois c'est la pire de Taïwan le
bémol
de la reconnaissance faciale à Taïwan
dans les rues
je ne pense pas il y a des caméras de
surveillance mais protection
de consulter quand il y a un crime qui
arrive on a le droit de consulter vous
gardez les données combien de temps
alors ça je n'ai pas beaucoup d'idées
mais je ne pense pas qu'on les garde
longtemps et je sais que s'il y a une
manipulation
déjà il y a pas de reconnaissance
faciale donc Messian une manipulation de
de qui a peut-être but politique je
crois immédiatement ça va être balancé
dans la presse et en alerte oui si vous
voulez ouais et puis la personne qui
décide de faire ça n'aura plus ne pourra
plus supporter cette sorte de d'attaque
venant de la société
civile regardez récemment on a aussi un
problème parce que il y a deux ans entre
deux ans le gouvernement avait voulu
faire une carte d'identité
numérique pour
j'ai compris c'était numérique parce que
moi je suis pas Taïwan mais c'est vrai
qu'on pouvait conserver certaines
données
non c'était c'est une carte une carte
électrique moderne passons maintenant
notre pièce d'identité c'est c'est comme
c'est comme le permis de conduire rose
notre numéro d'identité le numéro
national ni dans les Nationales c'est
pas du tout numérique donc le gouver
avait voulu mettre en donner une carte
moderne qui fait conserver
certains données de notre santé tout ça
ça a été fortement critiqué en disant ça
va permettre à une sorte de je veux dire
oui et donc ça a été annulé ce projet
donc moi je pense à Taïwan le système
démocratique permet nous permet vraiment
à maintenir beaucoup de liberté et aussi
que nous défendons ici avec vous à la
France
les habitants les habitants de Taïwan
quand ils vont en Chine il y en a qui
vont en Chine ils y vont avec quel
passeport alors là c'est le plus
intéressant comme la Chine ne reconnaît
pas notre passeport il nous donne
en se basant sur les informations non
passeports il nous donnant une autre
carte d'identité
carte d'identité chinoise voilà ce qu'il
espère le faire et donc
quand on va en Chine il regarde pas le
passeport mais regarde la carte le
papier qui l'ont donné et c'est je crois
bien parce que ça fait longtemps que je
suis pas allé en Chine maintenant c'est
devenu une carte d'identité comme comme
une carte de crédit de quelque chose
comme ça je pense ça fait combien de
temps vous êtes pas allé en Chine depuis
que vous avez vous
occupez des positions officielles déjà
je crois la dernière fois quand j'étais
en Chine doit être 2014 j'étais une
immense trois fois en Chine
une fois une semaine
fois ça doit être un Enquin trois fois
non jamais
ils ont demandé d'aller là-bas non je
crois il y a beaucoup terminé non plus
qui m'ont pas en Chine maintenant parce
que si vous avez peur pour votre
sécurité
moi-même celle de vos enfants de votre
famille de vos cousins
pas tellement à Taïwan il ne craint rien
comme comme je veux dire comme problème
de sécurité moi-même ici je fais
confiance dans la France
n'est-ce pas donc la France est foutue
des
îles politiques et Julien sont joués
Édouard Snowden moi je crève
la France quand même défend bien ça ça
souveraineté vous n'avez pas trop de
problèmes de de sécurité
pour des dipomates ou des étrangers qui
sont installés ici pour travailler
est-ce que vous avez envie d'aborder un
sujet qu'on n'a pas abordé non c'est
bien je crois j'ai pas regardé ma montre
mais je sais pas ça va durer là on est
que à deux heures pour ça c'est ça c'est
déjà la première fois que je me suis
interviewé si longtemps il y a beaucoup
de premières fois pour moi en France
quand je crois c'est en 1996 qu'on avait
eu
la première c'est à dire qu'on a eu une
entre 1er élection présidentielle à
taewei moi je t'ai étudiant ici et
les Chinois ont fait des manœuvres
militaires pour empêcher la première
démocratie pour nous dissuader de ne pas
effectuer cette élection présidentielle
alors à cette époque là pour moi c'est
la première de ma vie d'être je me
souviens encore d'être interviewé sur
France 2 en étant étudiant pour parler
un peu de la situation il y a
quelques jours on m'avait fait aussi un
portrait sur libération alors jamais
j'étais ma photo était
présentée dans un quotidien aussi
important mais ma taille moyenne jamais
j'avais été présenté de cette façon là
et aujourd'hui de parler d'être
interviewé pendant deux heures
même en chinois je n'avais jamais fait
vous avez regardé vous allez regarder
quoi de nos productions sur notre chaîne
YouTube alors je voulais dire j'ai vu
bien sûr l'interview de Monsieur
Louchard je crois si ça dure deux heures
je crois que j'ai eu la chance oui
c'était 3h30
après j'ai vu à la juillet j'ai vu
Hubert V j'ai vu Mélenchon voilà c'est à
peu près ce que j'ai vu parce que vos
interviews sont longs mais si j'ai le
temps je vais continuer à regarder
comment les autres ont été interviewés
est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté
alors
j'ai des professeurs mais je reconnais
depuis 6 ans je ne lis plus
je suis tellement pris par mon boulot
pour
faire ce que je crains le crâne
d'invasion chinoise et donc je
j'ai la conviction qu'on peut éviter
cette invasion chinoise
en trouvant des autres moyens pour
dissuader la Chine donc ce que j'avais
dit si nous parlons une immense des mois
militaires c'est on s'orientait on
s'orientera forcément vers des
résolutions militaires donc ce que moi
je milite beaucoup je parle beaucoup
avec vos parlementaires donc c'est pour
ça en 2000 je crois 21 on a eu une
résolution du Sénat d'un vote de 304
contre 0 pour soutenir Taïwan après ça
s'est produit la même chose pour
l'Assemblée nationale je parle beaucoup
avec des journalistes maintenant
regardez maintenant
je crois que la façon que nous
présentons maintenant les relations
entre la terre et la Chine a beaucoup
évolué depuis mon arrivée vous savez
avant vous utilisez souvent le mot
unification et rééducation vous savez à
chaque fois quand vous parlez d'une
éducation ou réinification ou donner
raison à la Chine d'attaquer Taïwan et
c'est quelque chose qui est très
embêtant donc si jamais la Chine fait
quelque chose sur Taïwan c'est une
invasion une conquête alors je vois de
plus en plus ces mots qui sont sortis
que ce n'est plus une unification une
réunification quand je vois des cartes
géopolitiques qui sont sorties
maintenant dans la presse et bien avant
taïwanachine c'est toujours dans le même
couleur maintenant sont dans les
couleurs différentes je suis toujours
pas d'ambassade
je vous ai dit la vie n'est pas parfaite
donc nous faisons tous nos mieux pour
essayer d'améliorer les choses donc là
ce sont des évolutions très importantes
l'année dernière j'étais interviewé par
la presse française oui
si la Chine attaque est-ce que vous
pensez que les États-Unis vont se
déployer certainement il y aura pas
simplement la Chine moi je pense tous
les pays dans la région vont vous savez
pour soutenir Taïwan il y a mille façons
c'est comme ici en France pour la guerre
du crâne vous soutenez les graines en
leur donnant des canons César nous ne
sommes pas capables de donner des
annonces Césars dont nous interrompons
nos exportations des puces vers la
Russie donc ce sont des façons
différentes ce nous espérons la France
c'est pareil donc moi ce que j'espère
que vous avez senti que la Russie avait
fait des provisions de puces chez vous
avant la guerre
ça c'est difficile à
dire parce que je ne pense pas parce que
je ne pense pas que la Russie avait
prévu une telle réaction de la
communauté internationale je crois la
Russie avec cru qu'ils allaient
terminer la guerre dans une semaine et
d'ailleurs c'est la pression que j'avais
eu aussi à l'époque je crois en 2022 au
mois de février j'avais plein d'amis qui
disait ah mais Zelinski va bientôt être
assassiné qui avait sera pris dans les
jours qui suivent c'est tout ça que
j'avais eu comme message donc je ne
pense pas parce que la poutine était
tellement confiante de son armée qui
pensait qu'il allait terminer guerre
dans les jours qui viennent donc je ne
pense pas qu'ils ont fait des provisions
des puces donc je reviens à ce que je
viens de dire donc là j'ai senti la
différence ça m'a beaucoup encouragé
c'est d'ailleurs
ce changement de façon que vous regardez
Taïwan je redis l'année dernière après
la visite aussi j'étais interview je
crois une dizaine une Vendée de fois
dans une semaine ça s'est jamais produit
pour moi aussi à terme j'étais pas un
professeur simple avant être
vice-ministre j'ai aussi j'allais
régulièrement dans la télévision mais
jamais une dizaine vingtaine de fois
dans dans 10 jours je sortais dans tous
les émissions et ça s'est refait bon
c'est vrai c'est pas si intensif mais
j'étais quand même assez interviewé
après la visite d'Emmanuel Macron en
Chine et puis leur manœuvre militaire
autour de Taïwan donc c'est des gens
discutent de plus en plus Taïwan et puis
ça vous avez quel a été votre lecture
après la visite d'Emmanuel Macron en
Chine le fait qu'il fasse des manœuvres
autour de Lille c'était pour dire à
Macron bon écoute tu vois rien regarde
ce qu'on va faire le lendemain comment
vous avez
perçu ça alors
je
je crois si nous regardons ce qui s'est
passé après il y a eu beaucoup il y a
une réaction de masse pour d'une
certaine façon soutenir Taïwan donc ça
veut dire que la voix de la France
compte la France a des influences
et ça ça aussi ça confirme ce que je
vous ai dit dans entre deux pays
démocratiques il y a rarement des
trahisons parce que comme on est libre
il y a plein de dire mais non non c'est
il faut pas dire de cette façon là les
relations entre Taïwan et la France donc
de ma part je crois monsieur Macron
avait beaucoup assisté sur la
l'autonomie stratégique
mais je regarde d'une façon positive ce
qui s'est passé après parce qu'il y a
tout de suite eu beaucoup de création de
Madame Catherine Colonna de
tous les membres du gouvernement en
disant que la position de la France n'a
pas changé en vertèbre et puis
d'ailleurs ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure la déclaration conjointe entre
le mystère de la défense des Affaires
étrangères français japonais
redit cette position française et
d'ailleurs je dois aussi dire des bonnes
choses de Monsieur Emmanuel Macron
c'est-à-dire la France a été le premier
pays d'Union européenne à mettre Taïwan
en étant un partenaire dans votre
stratégie ado pacifique et après
sur les déclarations du G7 du G20 la
France a nous avons beaucoup soutenu
sans jamais produit avant
Taïwan c'était un tabou maintenant bon
c'est aussi encore un petit tabou mais
on ose de plus en plus à parler Taïwan
donc je reviens sur ce je viens dire
plus nous parlons de Taïwan plus nous
envoyons des avertissements à la Chine
même ils sont jamais
d'accords ah non non quand par exemple
des des déclarations de de pour dire que
je vous ai dit que Taïwan la stabilité
one c'est indispensable pour pour le
monde ben c'est aussi des
investissements vers la Chine des
Américains c'est pareil les japonais
c'est pareil donc il faut
tous ces domaines dissuasion vers la
Chine pour que eux ils ne prennent pas
une une action militaire unilatérale et
donc moi je crois beaucoup à tout ça et
ce qui fait que
beaucoup plus libre ça me prend beaucoup
beaucoup de temps c'est des échange avec
la France c'est bien les longues
interviews
mais je suis fatigué là là vraiment à
tous trois livres qui ont compté pour
vous
dans votre vie à conseiller à notre
communauté
si vous voulez j'avais la grande
hypothée de Kissinger que je crois
j'avais beaucoup j'avais j'avais
beaucoup lu et puis la terre est plate
et
puis il y avait un livre qui parlait
qu'est-ce qu'il avait changé le monde
les gènes
l'acier et puis
j'ai plus la troisième élément
un livre des livres qui qui regardaient
le futur et que je crois que je l'avais
tout lu quand j'étais professeur mais
après
la question internet quelques
représentent le pin's sur votre veste ah
ici c'est
le bleu on sait le bleu oui je suis très
fier
du Mérite qu'est-ce qui vous a décoré
alors c'était à l'époque c'était
François Hollande mais moi j'étais
professeur ah oui j'étais aussi
président de la langue française à
Taïwan parce qu'à l'époque comme moi je
défends beaucoup la diversité à Taïwan
j'aimerais bien
c'est faire la France une partie Taïwan
vous allez rigoler et aussi que tu
arrives fait partie de la France
c'est-à-dire que la France joue un rôle
chez nous dans la région et c'est ça la
richesse de Taïwan c'est vraiment la
diversité donc quand je t'ai pris dans
la langue française à Taïwan je crois un
sondage disait que le français à
l'époque parce que maintenant c'est plus
de cas maintenant on prend beaucoup
d'immigration venant de la sud-est je
fais la langue française la troisième
langue étrangère le plus appris à Taïwan
derrière l'anglais japonais et français
et donc moi j'étais très fier et puis on
m'avait donné une décoration là-dessus
je pense mais pareil je ne suis pas venu
j'ai pas eu l'honneur ou la possibilité
de venir en France pour être décoré
personnellement par Monsieur le
Président François Hollande
le pin's le pin's c'est la mystère des
Affaires étrangères de Taïwan
il y a beaucoup de catholiques chez vous
non non je crois deux à trois pour cent
c'est un maximum alors d'ailleurs je
dois dire comme une chose très
importante quand la Chine elle est
devenue communiste les missionnaires les
pères qui ont été persécutés en Chine
c'est avec les accueillis
sans siège vous reconnais oui mais
j'espère que ça va continuer parce que
sinon l'essentiel je deviendra comme les
autres pays c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plus
d'intérêt en Chine on nous abandonne il
faut pas oublier qu'à l'époque c'était
nous qui avait accueilli tous ces
gens-là et puis ils ont joué à rôle
aussi pour
le catholicisme en Chine parce qu'il y
avait des des pères qui étaient qui
étaient formés à Taïwan avec la langue
chinoise après pour ensuite travailler
en Chine donc nous avons quand même joué
des rôles importants et puis surtout
quand
le 5 6 avec tous ces problèmes là c'est
Taïwan qui les a accueillis donc voilà
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer quelque chose d'un périssable qui
restera sur les réseaux
il faut il faut croire que avec nos
efforts on peut changer le monde
regardez enfin de ma part quand je garde
encore une fois il y a 5 ans il y a 6
ans quand la France regardait Taïwan
c'était pas du tout le cas d'aujourd'hui
le monde c'est pareil il faut que nous
continuons à croire qu'on peut changer
le monde et surtout il faut que je suis
tout à fait d'accord il faut croire à la
démocratie de la liberté et aussi au
développement durable et il faut faire
des efforts pour le changement
climatique c'est comme ça que je vois
aussi le futur de mes enfants je j'ai
tellement travaillé pour pour maintenir
la stabilité de
la région parce que mes enfants vont
vivre je dois aussi me battre pour cette
jeunesse et à la Genèse aussi doit
continuer à croire que on peut changer
le monde si chacun fait un geste
regardez par exemple
pour aller au bureau moi je crois je
suis un des rares ambassadeurs de marché
à peu près enfin j'essaye tous les jours
50 minutes et retour 50 minutes pour
faire un peu d'effort le livre en
question que vous parliez c'est pas gun
James
générations vous voulez rajouter un bout
non c'est à dire travaillons ensemble et
puis nous essayons de changer ce
monde-là et puis le monde du 21e siècle
ne doit pas être un monde de conflit de
guerre
on peut ne pas faire cette
d'éviter ces guerres si nous travaillons
ensemble
François shinksongu merci merci je suis
très content d'être interviewé par vous
et déjà de parler d'être interviewé en
français qui n'est pas ma langue
maternelle c'est un
peu dur non c'est bien
non mais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
un grand plaisir de pouvoir parler le
français pendant deux heures et puis
voilà il faut là aussi j'espère que le
français va continuer de jouer un rôle
dans ce monde il faut défendre le
français en étant en étranger et je
pense c'est comme ça que le monde va
continuer à fonctionner et parce que
avec en parlant français nous nous
réfléchissons d'une façon différente et
c'est important pour notre monde la
diversité motorisez vous vous appelez
François hou oui bien sûr bien sûr merci
merci
[Musique]